Heute im Rasenfunk?
Tentu Kian Mbappé.
Kian!
Irgendwann habe ich meine Gäste in der Liga Tour soweit, dass sie oberkörperfrei die Tore ihres jeweiligen Landes bejubeln. So ist es jetzt schon fast für alle, die uns bei YouTube sehen. Die haben schon die Andeutung davon gemerkt. Und damit Hallo und herzlich Willkommen hier im Rasenfunk in der Liga Tour. Wir wollen sprechen über die europäischen Top-League bei den Männern. Und dazu begrüße ich bei mir David Frangier de Pont-le-Vain für die Ligue 1. Hallo David.
Hallo.
Wir kennen dich natürlich von 93. Kein Stadt, kein Gott, kein Staat. 93. Keine Stadt, kein Dorf. 93 wäre auch nicht schlecht. Außerdem hier Alex Treuker für La Liga. Hallo Alex.
Grüß dich, Servus.
Es gibt was Neues zu La Liga. Das kannst du doch jetzt hier placken. Oder habe ich doch jetzt richtig verstanden? Jetzt ist es offiziell gelauncht. Nicht mehr so, dass wir geschändet werden, wenn wir draufklicken von euch.
Es gibt was Neues. Eine kleine neue La Liga Website, ein La Liga Hub sozusagen. Also eine Website, wo man nicht nur über Real und Barcelona informiert wird. Die einschlägigen Websiten kennt man ja. Sondern wirklich auch über die spanische Liga. Im Allgemeinen über La Liga. Die Website heißt vivalaliga.de. Also schön klangvoller Name. Und ja, kann ich jedem ans Herz legen. So ungefähr. Kann ich jedem ans Herz legen, mal vorbei zu gucken. Ich habe nämlich heute mal zwei Themen mitgebracht, die eben nicht Barcelona Real sind. Und das sind so typische Themen, die könnte man auch auf La Liga konsumieren zum Beispiel.
Also viva la liga.de, wir von der Ligatur. Wir wussten es schon früher, aber wir wurden hart dafür abgestraft, dass wir gefragt haben, ob wir das jetzt schon bekannt geben dürfen. Denn ganz offensichtlich sei die Website ja noch nicht fertig gewesen. Ich habe es nicht gemacht, aber schön, dass ihr jetzt offiziell gelauncht habt. Und außerdem hier ist Marius Solke von Serie Amore, also für die Serie A. Hallo Marius, schön, dass du da bist. Ja, das finde ich auch. Die Premier League werden wir auch abfrühstücken mit Jogi Hebel. Das wird ein einziges Segment, was wir nach diesem Part hier aufzeichnen. Wir starten jetzt aber rein und ich würde sagen, komm Marius, wenn du jetzt gerade hier schon als letzter Hallo sagen durftest, dann darfst du mit deinem ersten Thema beginnen. Was hast du uns denn mitgebracht aus der Serie A?
Ich habe zum einen mitgebracht den amtierenden Meister, die SSC Napoli, die sich so ein bisschen in einer ersten kleinen Krise in dieser Saison befindet. Ihr erinnert euch, wie schon vor einem Jahr, als das dann ganz wunderbar geklappt hat und man am Ende Meister wurde, gab es auch in diesem Sommer einen relativ großen Umbruch mit Stammspielern, die gegangen sind, Kim zu den Bayern natürlich, und vor allem auch ist der Meistertrainer gegangen, Spalletti, und der Sportdirektor Giuntulli und der neue Trainer, Ruedi Garcia. David kennt ihn aus Frankreich bestens. Das ist schon von vornherein relativ viel kritisiert worden, seine Verpflichtung, weil er seine letzte Station eben nicht bei einem europäischen Top-Club, sondern bei Al Nasser hatte. Den als den Nachfolger für den so sehr geliebten Spalletti zu verpflichten, das hat nicht unbedingt für so viel Verständnis gesorgt. Auch wenn man sich eigentlich zurückerinnert, er hat bei der Roma ziemlich gut lange gute Arbeit geleistet, hat auch attraktiven Fußball spielen lassen. Aber jetzt haben wir acht Spiele in der Liga rum, und zwar in der Champions League. Und im Endeffekt steht da ein fünfter Platz für Napoli mit 14 Punkten. Das ist erstmal eigentlich gar nicht so mega schlecht, würde ich sagen, aber der Rückstand auf Tabellenführer Milan beträgt bereits sieben Punkte in der Champions League. Klar kann man zu Hause gegen Real verlieren, aber natürlich hat man sich in Napoli immer sehr emotional und so auch erhofft, dass man dieses erste richtig große Duell in der Saison gewinnt. Das ist dann, finde ich, relativ unglücklich, 2 zu 3 verloren gegangen. Aber wie unglücklich das gewesen ist, das interessiert dann in der Rückbetrachtung ja meistens nicht mehr so viel. Und jetzt gab es am Wochenende ein 1 zu 3 gegen Florenz, die in der Saison vorher 8er geworden sind und natürlich eine gute Mannschaft sind, aber das entspricht natürlich überhaupt nicht dem Bild von Napoli und der Präsident De Laurentiis hat sich danach vor die Mikros gestellt und den Trainer Rüdiger hier quasi öffentlich demontiert, könnte man sagen.
Jetzt schon?
Also jetzt schon. Und was er gesagt hat, lese ich einfach irgendwie einmal so vor. Wir haben im Moment keine gute Situation mit Rüdiger hier, wenn man sich für einen Trainer entscheidet, der den italienischen Fußball offensichtlich nicht mehr kennt, kann das passieren. Und ich werde die beste Entscheidung am richtigen Moment treffen und werde mich von den Fans da nicht beeinflussen lassen.
Das ist deutlicher als das, was man hier immer hört mit Ja, wir werden uns natürlich zusammensetzen und alles hinterfragen. Mal gucken und dann melden wir uns wieder.
Weiß man denn, was die Beweggründe waren, warum man ihn ausgesucht hat? Also Spielstil oder was hat man sich von ihm erhofft konkret?
Ja, ein Trainer, der schon in der Lage ist, ein ähnliches, sehr variables, technisch versiertes Offensivspiel, wie Spalletti das vorher und wie Napoli das ja seit Jahren eigentlich pflegt, auch auf die Beine zu stellen. Und dann hat man sich wahrscheinlich an die Zeiten in Lille und in Rom zurückerinnert. Und vielleicht, ich kann seine Arbeit in Lyon nicht so gut beurteilen, aber vielleicht die letzten Jahre so ein bisschen ausgeblendet und einfach den Namen genommen, auch weil es vielleicht auch mit anderen Trainern nicht geklappt hat. Also man wollte, das wäre mein zweites Thema, der letzte Gegner eben, Florenz, sehr gerne auch Vincenzo Italiano verpflichten. Da wurde abgelehnt, man hätte auch Tiago Motta, von Bologna genommen, die haben auch abgelehnt. De Laurentiis hat auch zugegeben, dass er mit Luis Enrique gesprochen hat. Er hat dann in einem Nebensatz eingeschoben, dass er ganz glücklich ist, dass es nicht geklappt hat, weil man sieht ja jetzt sehr, jetzt in Paris, was der zu leisten imstande ist. Na ja, ist er ja auch so ein kleiner großer Populist, der Herr De Laurentiis.
Das heißt, Rudi Garcia war so quasi mindestens Plan B, so ein bisschen so wie damals, als der FC Bayern Thomas Tuchel zu spät angerufen hat. Und dann kam Nico Kovac.
Wahrscheinlich. Also so offensiv ist das natürlich nicht kommuniziert worden. Er ist natürlich als die Wunschlösung präsentiert worden. Aber dass man gerne einen der jüngeren aufstrebenden italienischen Trainer verpflichtet hätte, das ist eigentlich kein Geheimnis. Mal sehen, wie lange es jetzt weitergeht. Und vor allem, was denn dann die Alternativen sind. Denn viele hoffen natürlich, dass dann jetzt vielleicht Italiano kommen würde. Aber das geht nicht. Denn in Italien darf ein Trainer nur eine Mannschaft pro Saison trainieren. Was? Den Trainer vom Konkurrenten wegkaufen. Das geht nicht. Und dann kam eigentlich jetzt über Nacht quasi die zweite Bombe. Schon am Tage hatte es Berichte gegeben, vom Kollegen Romano unter anderem, dass De Laurentiis sich mit Antonio Conte zusammengesetzt hätte. Und der hat mehr oder weniger später bestätigt, dass er mit großen Vereinen gesprochen hat. Aber gesagt hat, er möchte jetzt noch nicht wieder irgendwo einsteigen. Sondern sich seiner Familie widmen. Ob es dann letztlich am Angebot gelegen hat oder...
Deswegen hat er mit denen gesprochen, ja?
Ja, genau.
Das war quasi das Gespräch.
Das tut mir leid. Aus Respekt lehnt man dann so einen Gesprächsvorschlag natürlich nicht ab. Oder? Ich weiß es nicht. Auf jeden Fall, ja, die öffentliche Demontage von Rudi Garcia geht damit natürlich irgendwie komplett weiter. Und bei Napoli werden das relativ heiße Wochen auch, weil gut, am nächsten Spieltag geht es zu Hellas. Das ist natürlich eigentlich ein Pflichtsieg, aber Ende des Monats spielen sie dann auch noch gegen Milan. Und wenn man das verlieren sollte, dann ist man schon zehn Punkte zurück, wenn Milan auch am nächsten Spieltag wiederum gegen Juve gewinnen sollte. Das kann man sich dann eigentlich als Titelverteidiger vom eigenen Selbstverständnis her nicht erlauben.
Ich meine, das muss man ja dazu sagen, quasi zu der Schärfe der Debatte gehört eben dazu, dass mit Milan jemand gerade mit 21 Punkten aus acht spielen, also nur einmal verloren gegen Inter, halt richtig davon klust und da eben die Sorge ist, dass man den Anschluss verliert, mit sieben Punkten Rückstand ja auch nicht ganz unzurecht, zu unrecht. Spielt denn die Debatte rund um Viktor Osimen noch eine Rolle, die wir das letzte Mal angesprochen haben? Da haben wir nämlich leider einen ganz wesentlichen Part ausgelassen, das ist mir leider auch durchgerutscht, nämlich, dass es ja quasi Aufregung um TikTok-Videos gab, ein Teil ein älteres Video und ein neueres Video, und er hatte dann einen Bezug zu Neapel auf seinem Instagram-Account gelöscht. Wichtig ist aber dazu zu wissen, dass da Coconut als Begriff drin vorkam, und das ist ein rassistisch verwendeter Begriff, der eben Menschen dunkler Hautfarbe abwerten soll. Das ist natürlich eine ganz wichtige Komponente, die wir aber leider in der letzten Ligatur nicht erwähnt haben. Hat sich das irgendwie aufgelöst? Spielt das irgendwie eine Rolle? Wir hatten ja Neapel schon letztes Mal hier in der Ligatur als Thema. Es ist ja generell sehr emotional, hat es Christian Werner das letzte Mal genannt, da gerade. Es wird gerade viel über Dinge diskutiert, die jetzt gar nicht nur mit Sport zu tun haben.
Ich glaube, das passt einfach aus negativer Sicht ganz gut ins Bild, dass es so eine Debatte dann irgendwie noch on top kommt, die aber, ich weiß nicht, wie es in der Stadt selbst ist, aber im Grunde genommen mittlerweile abgeschlossen ist. Ozyman hat sich ungefähr eine Woche nach dem Vorfall nochmal an die Fans gewandt und gesagt, uns bringt niemand auseinander, ihr habt mir so viel gegeben, der Verein hat mir so viel gegeben, natürlich kann ich mir vorstellen, zu verlängern und so weiter und so fort. Da sind die Wogen zumindest öffentlich offensichtlich geglättet und er hat die Entschuldigung des Vereins, die er auch zuerst jetzt zumindest öffentlich gar nicht so groß ausgefallen ist, sondern irgendwie eher so lapidar mit einem Post. Aber er hat es offensichtlich angenommen und er hat auch in den nächsten drei Ligaspielen jeweils getroffen und entsprechend die Reaktion auf den Platz gezeigt und sich da auch nicht irgendwie von Fans, Mannschaft, Trainerverein oder so distanziert oder abgewandt, sondern schon so emotional gejubelt und so, wie er das sonst auch gemacht hat.
Okay, also das wollte ich nur an dieser Stelle noch erwähnen, weil das dann doch ein größerer Fauxpas war, dass uns das in der Besprechung durchgerutscht ist in der letzten Ausgabe. Dann blicken wir mal nach Spanien. Da haben wir nämlich schon den ersten Trainerwechsel, so wie in der Bundesliga. Das heißt, die Frage, die ich schon immer mal stellen wollte, wer ist der FC Augsburg Spaniens, Alex?
Wer der FC Augsburg Spaniens ist, weiß ich jetzt so nicht, um die Metapher zu bauen. Aber Sevilla ist sicherlich nicht der FC Augsburg Spaniens, denn die beiden kannst du nicht vergleichen. Aber Sevilla hat jetzt eben seinen Coach entlassen. Mendilibar ist nicht mehr Trainer. Und man erinnert sich, der kam ja letztes Frühjahr, als die Not ganz groß war bei Sevilla, als Notnadel, um sie irgendwie vor dem Abstieg zu retten oder dass sie nicht noch mehr da unten reinrutschen nach einer katastrophalen Saison. Und am Ende stand einfach mal wieder, wie oft, der Europa League Sieg, ihr Lieblingswettbewerb. Den haben sie unter ihm gewonnen. Also das war wirklich sensationell, dass er nicht nur sie vor dem Abstieg rettet und konsolidiert in La Liga, sondern wirklich wieder den zweiten europäischen Wettbewerb gewonnen hat. Also ein ganz, ganz besonderes Ding, weil er noch nie als Trainer einen Pokal gewinnen konnte. Der immer so in der 2. Liga, in der 3. Liga gecoacht. Noch viele Abstiegskandidaten, also Augsburg-Mannschaften in La Liga gecoacht von der Kragenweite. Und das war so mit Abstand der größte Verein. Und dass er dann direkt mit, ich weiß gar nicht, wie alt er ist, 60 irgendwas, seinen ersten Pokal gewinnt, war sensationell. Ja, aber lange hat es nicht angehalten. Jetzt am 9. Spieltag oder jetzt gerade quasi vor zwei Tagen war dann doch wieder überraschend Schluss, weil Sevilla wieder nicht richtig in die Pütte kommt in La Liga.
Also nur zwei Siege aus acht Spielen. Man hat nur acht Punkte. Aktuell Tabellen 14. ist Sevilla. Aber woran liegt denn das? Also weil es wird ja nicht nur an Mendy Liba liegen, sonst wären wir ja nicht letztes Jahr schon so schlecht gewesen.
Genau, ich fand auch, dass es überraschend kam, dass sie ihn jetzt so schnell wieder entlassen haben. Es ist halt diese typische Länderspielpause. Immer wenn es nicht läuft und die Länderspielpause kommt, dann glaube ich, sind die Vereine nochmal mehr trigger happy. Also wahrscheinlich auch Augsburg, weil man sich immer denkt, in diesen 10, 14 Tagen kann vielleicht ein neuer Coach, wenn er installiert wird, dann mehr leisten, als wenn du dann ständig englische Wochen hast. Also sicherlich auch dem Zeitpunkt ein bisschen geschuldet, dass man da die Nerven verloren hat. Denn so würde ich schon ein bisschen titulieren wollen. Also für mich persönlich kam es überraschend, vor allem zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt. Ja, sie hatten einen Fehlstart. Sie waren in den ersten drei Spielen ohne Punkt geblieben, waren an Tabellen letzter. Aber es ist nicht so, dass alles katastrophal war, dass du unbedingt den Trainer wechseln musst. Das war letztes Jahr eher anders als Lopetegui, ihr eigentlicher Erfolgscoach, mit dem sie natürlich auch die Europa League gewonnen haben, dann im Herbst gehen musste. Da war es ja schon so, dass es gar nicht mehr weiterging. Da war ich ja teilweise sogar im Stadion bei zwei Spielen gegen Barca und Man City. Und da war wirklich Krisenstimmung pur. Sie haben ständig verloren, Heimspiele auch hoch verloren. Du hast gemerkt, die Fans schreien nach Veränderungen. Nicht unbedingt nach Lopetegui's Kopf, aber wirklich nach Veränderungen. Und da war es klar, es geht nicht weiter. Das war jetzt so und eigentlich nicht der Fall. Sie waren nur ein bisschen unkonstant, Sevilla. Sie haben auch ein bisschen underperformed, aber dann wieder einen Sieg geholt. Gegen Barca ein gutes Spiel gemacht, spät verloren. In der Champions League hätten sie um 1h in Eindhoven gewonnen. Da gab es den Gegentreffer in der 95. Minute. Bei 5 Minuten Abspielzeit hätten sie auch um 1h 3 Punkte geholt in einem schweren Spiel. Zuhause aber, gegen L'Anse, enttäuscht, nur 1 zu 1 gespielt. Diese Unstetigkeit, dass sie keine Konstanz in ihren Leistung, vor allem aber in den Resultaten, reinbrachten, das wurde so ein bisschen zu Verhängnis. Die Frage ist, ob sie wirklich underperformed haben oder vielleicht ist das aktuell leider nur das Niveau der Mannschaft, dass sie nicht sonderlich viel besser sind.
Ja, vor allem, das ist ja gerade Champions League. Sie werden ja erst in der Europa League wieder alles gewinnen. Das weiß man doch.
Sie sind ja aktuell auch Dritter.
Dann wird sie die Europa League gewinnen können, genau.
Ganz genau, sie sind auf Kurs.
Das ist ja absolut unverständlich. Und jetzt ist ja der Nachfolger, wenn ich es richtig sehe, steht ja schon bereit. Erzähl uns doch mal ein bisschen was über Diego Alonso.
Ja, das ist das Überraschende. Wenn du wieder sagst, Mendilibar unter ihm kann die Mannschaft mehr erreichen, und das war ja offensichtlich der Gedanke, und er holt nicht das Maximum raus, würdest du dir normalerweise denken, okay, sie haben einen richtig guten großen Namen. Also groß im Sinne von nicht, dass er der Star-Trainer ist. Das ist schon klar.
Alonso ist ein sehr großer Name in vielen Sportarten.
Genau, aber ich meine, ein Trainer, bei dem du eine gewisse Erwartung, Haltung hast oder bei dem du weißt, der wird die Mannschaft definitiv besser machen. Die Frage ist, ist das unter Diego Alonso der Fall? Die Antwort kann dir keiner in Spanien liefern, denn er hat noch nie in Europa gecoacht. Also er ist ein Uruguayer, der zuletzt bei der WM 22 die Uruguayische Nationalmannschaft betreut hat. Man weiß ja, da sind sie auch enttäuschend in der Gruppenphase ausgeschieden, in einer sehr machbaren Gruppe. War davor viel in Südamerika unterwegs, ich glaube, bei Pena Roll gecoacht und verschiedene Vereine in Südamerika und in Spanien als Spieler zwar gespielt, aber eben nicht trainiert. Also in Europa, irgendwo ein unbeschriebenes Blatt, jetzt auch nicht zuletzt die Monster-Erfolgsstory gehabt bei Uruguay und dadurch überrascht es dann schon, dass er dann der Nachfolger ist. Also schon ein bisschen ein Gamble, ein Risiko, eine Ungewissheit, die du da mit diesem Namen verbindest und interessanterweise hat er natürlich auch nur einen Vertrag bis Saisonende, was ja irgendwie passt. Also von daher kann ich dir nicht mit Sicherheit sagen, jetzt wird alles besser. Ich glaube, das kann dir keiner in Sevilla, sondern es ist schon ein bisschen, ich will es nicht Panikmove nennen, aber ein bisschen Geschmäckle hat es ja.
Ja, aber andererseits ja interessant, dass man so auf so jemanden kommt. Also vor allem, wenn ja quasi der letzte Trainerwechsel war ja so der Peter Neururer Spaniens. Also wir holen halt den oder der Felix Magarder, der hat quasi schon mal die halbe Liga vom Aufstieg gesetzt.
Also ja, einen alten Veteran, aber nicht so altmodisch. Die Liga ist ja nicht aus der Zeit gefallen, sondern das war halt...
Hey, Felix Magard sagt auch, er könnte Nationaltrainer sein.
Ich überlege gerade, was ein besserer Vergleich wäre. So ein Labardier ist er aber in 10, 15 Jahren älter.
Und das war jetzt besser, ja?
Na ja, komm, Labardier ist ja wohl die bessere Wahl als Neururer, Max.
Ja gut, als Neururer, ja. Aber Felix Magard und Bruno Labardier, die begegnen sich dann, glaube ich, schon auf Augenhöhe.
Okay, Ansichtssache, Ansichtssache, gut.
Zumindest was das Selbstbewusstsein angeht. Aber was ich ja eigentlich sagen wollte, ist, ich immer mit meinen schiefen Bundesligas vergleichen. Aber da fühle ich mich halt wohl in der Bundesliga. Da kenne ich mich aus. Also jetzt dann zu dem ehemaligen Trainer Uruguays zu wechseln, der vorher eben, du hast es ja gesagt, nur im Ausland gecoachert, bei Inter Miami war er vor Uruguay. Das sind jetzt auch keine Riesensprünge von ihm zu beobachten gewesen. Da muss ja etwas dahinter stehen. Also auf so jemanden kommt man ja nicht aus Verlegenheit.
Mittlerweile, aber damals nicht. Ja, es gibt eine kleine Parallele zu dem, was Marius gesagt hat. Auch in Spanien ist die gleiche Regelung, dass ein Trainer, der schon mal in der Saison gecoacht hat, woanders, in Spanien nicht verpflichtet werden darf. Also auch da kannst du nicht jemanden schon nehmen, der woanders schon entlassen wurde. Also auch da, ein Trainer darf nur pro Saison einen Verein haben. Das grenzt natürlich die Wahl grundsätzlich ein. Das macht es schwieriger, jemanden zu finden. Dementsprechend sind nicht so viele Coaches available. Das ist der eine Grund. Und der andere Grund ist, müsste man den Sportdirektor Orta fragen, was ihn getrieben hat zu dieser Wahl. Öffentlich geäußert hat man sich da, glaube ich, noch nicht. Also ich kann dir nicht sagen, was man sich erwartet. Ich kann auch, das ist natürlich ein bisschen das Problem, dir nicht sagen, welchen Spielstil er verfolgt, weil ich jetzt den südamerikanischen Fußball oder auch Inter Miami vor der Messi-Zeit jetzt nicht so verfolgt habe, dass ich dir sage, boah.
Warum lade ich dich denn hier ein?
Nee, ist einfach schwierig zu sagen, lässt er jetzt übelst das Angriffspressing spielen oder ist er eher dafür bekannt, reaktionär verteidigen zu lassen und umzuschalten, kann ich leider nicht bewerten, weil ich den südamerikanischen Fußball so genau nicht verfolge. Ich weiß, dass er bei Uruguay mit Vorschusslorbeeren gestartet ist, dass er wirklich einen aktiven Spielstil verfolgt hat. Allein bei der WM, wo ich jedes Uruguay-Spiel gesehen habe, konnte man es nicht beobachten. Da war es eher wieder das typische Tabariss-Uruguay. Hinten dicht und dann guckt man mal, ob man umschalten kann. Deswegen, ja, schwer zu sagen. Er ist ein bisschen ein unbeschriebenes Blatt und das macht eben diese Personalie umso, ja, kurioser ein bisschen, finde ich.
Und es geht ja jetzt dann auch schmackhaft weiter mit dem Heimspiel gegen Real am Wochenende. Also da könnte er aber auch gleich eine Visitenkarte mit der Größe des Lebenlaufs von Felix Maggert oder Bruno Labbadia abgeben. Wie ich das jetzt hinbekommen habe, ich weiß es doch auch nicht. Leute, lasst uns über die Liga sprechen. David, auch du hast uns zwei Themen mitgebracht. Womit magst du anfangen?
Na, ihr habt mir jetzt so große Brücken gebaut, weil wir ja über Trainer, das Thema scheint ja anscheinend Trainer zu sein und da müssen wir über Nizza reden. Und es ist natürlich tatsächlich sehr, sehr witzig, dass wir jetzt gerade über einen französischen Trainer in Italien gesprochen haben und jetzt werden wir über einen italienischen Trainer in Frankreich reden. Und wir haben ja eine rare Flut von italienischen Trainern. Wir haben Fabio Grosso in Lyon, wir haben Genaro Gattuso in Marseille. Und schon im Sommer war klar, dass Francesco Farioli nach Nizza kommt. Das war relativ überraschend, weil der Interimstrainer Didier Degas hat gar nicht so einen schlechten Job gemacht. Der K-Master U23 war gar nicht so unerfolgreich. Da sind einige davon ausgegangen, dass er offiziell zum Trainer der 1. Mannschaft befördert wird. Nein, stattdessen hat man sich für Farioli entschieden. Und der hat eine relativ faszinierende Geschichte. Also erst mal ist er sehr jung. Der ist aktuell, oh Gott, jetzt habe ich es nicht. 33, 34? Er ist ein Schüler von De Zerbi. Und zwar ist er ein Schüler von De Zerbi, weil er mit 28 einen Artikel über ihn geschrieben hat. Und der mochte den Text von ihm dann so sehr, dass er ihn in sein Team eingeladen hat.
Das ist der italienische Rene Marit.
Und er war dann mit ihm in Beneveto und in Sassolo. Und er hat sich dann selbstständig gemacht, ist nach Indien zur Türkei gegangen, hat dort Alanyaspor und Kara Gümrük gecoacht. War da schon mit 31 Jahren der jüngste Chef-Trainer einer europäischen Pro-Liga, sagen mir die Statistiken. Ich muss jetzt ebenfalls gestehen, ich verfolge die türkische Liga nicht so sehr. Ich kann das also auch nur aus dem rausziehen, was ich jetzt gelesen habe. Galta offenbar als offensiver, als kreativer Trainer. Ballbesitzspiel, kurze Pässe, wenig Flanken. Wird dir gefallen, Max. Er hatte auch in der Türkei durchaus Phasen, wo er so sein Team all over the place war. Aber wenn ich dann mal kurz google, finde ich Artikel wie Faryoli's Revolution bei Kara Gümrük. Oder warum Faryoli aktuell einer der spannendsten Trainer der Welt ist. Also tatsächlich galt er und wurde auch so vorgestellt bei Nizza als ein bisschen der heiße Scheiß am Trainerhimmel. Der Start war dann, wie nicht anders zu erwarten, Mau. Zwei Punkte nach drei Spielen. Unter anderem ein 0-0 gegen Lyon. Über Lyon haben wir ja vor zwei Wochen schon mal gesprochen. Die sind bis heute sieglos. Das ist jetzt also kein Ruhmesblatt. Und das war dann auch der Moment, wo dann von den Fans die Piffe kamen und die Medien schrieben, na ja, das war ja aber eine sehr riskante Wahl und war das vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel Hype. Dann gab es einen Kommentar von Dante nach der Niederlage. Der wurde als Kritiksohr am Trainer gewertet. Dante, wohlgemerkt, ist fünf Jahre älter als sein Trainer. Ja, also auch das ja immer großartige Situationen in der Kabine, vermutlich, wenn die Spieler älter sind als die Trainer. Und das hat sich jetzt aber alles geändert. Seit dem spektakulären Sieg gegen PSG. Und gleich darauf nach noch dem Derbisee gegen Monaco. Das ist die einzige Niederlage von Spitzenreiter Monaco, die sie bekommen haben. Und Nizza ist immer noch ungeschlagen nach acht Spielen. Vier Siege, vier Unentschieden. Angeblich die beste Verteidigung Europas, konnte ich jetzt so nicht verifizieren. Also nur vier Tore in acht Spielen. Ich habe geschaut, die Eintracht hat zumindest schon mal ein Tor mehr. Bei einem Spiel weniger.
Es sagt viel über dich aus, dass du da zuerst an die Eintracht denkst.
Ja, es ist vielleicht nicht ganz so überraschend. Und gegen PSG konnte man aber tatsächlich auch schon sehen, was dann das Spiel von Fariola aus macht. Also flache Bälle, plötzlich Rhythmuswechsel, Gegner überraschen, Spiel stark über die Mitte spielen, enge Räume dicht beieinander bleiben, ständig den Gegner zurechtlegen, so dieses klassische. Und dann aber überraschend sein, gern auch mal so überraschend sein, dass man wirklich Lücken reißt, unerwartet sein, ein bisschen unkonventionell sein, aber eben relativ eng von hinten aufbauen. Und das war genau das, was gegen Lyon dann halt die Piffe hervorgerufen hat, weil das sah dann so aus, als hätten sich die zwei, oder was heißt das, als hätten, also sie haben es, die beiden Innenverteidiger passen sich die ganze Zeit die Bälle zu. Der Torwart ist stark eingebunden, alle stehen relativ ungewöhnlich am Strafraum, stehen dann oft beim Aufbauspiel fünf, sechs Leute, weil die zentralen Mittelfeldspieler auch noch zurückkommen. Dadurch ziehst du aber dann den Gegner raus, wenn es klappt. Da hast du dadurch hinten Lücken, während der Rest des Teams in diese Lücken rein stößt. Das hat bei Paris richtig gut funktioniert. Wir haben auch dann Risiko hoch angelaufen. Es ist jetzt auch nicht so ganz so ungefährlich, gegen einen Mbappé dann im Angriff hoch zu stehen. Man muss sagen, aktuell ist diese Achse, Dante, Todi Bo ist eventuell das beste Innenverteidiger-Duo der Liga. Ich habe Dante vor zwei Wochen schon mal gelobt. Ich habe extra nochmal nachgeschaut, der galt auch bei sehr vielen Vorschau-Blicken. Wo wird Netz seinen landen? Na ja, das ist schon ein Sicherheitsrisiko mit dem Alter. Aktuell ist davon nichts zu sehen. Todi Bo ist in der absoluten Form seines Lebens. 190 Ballkontakte in einem Spiel hat er jetzt gemacht. Damit hat er den Rekord seit Opta die Statistiken erhebt. Vormaliger Rekord war auch von Litze aus dem Jahr 2017. Und er hat noch 181 Pässe. Damit hat er einen gewissen Thiago Motta vom Morgen des Platzes gestoßen. Davon kamen noch 165 Pässe an. Der ist unglaublich wichtig im Spielaufbau. Das ist genau das, was ich über Fahrioli gelesen habe in der Türkei. Genau das, was er will. Also starke Innenverteidiger, die da klug aufbauen. Im Offensive klappt es noch nicht ganz so gut. 8 Tore in 7 Spielen. Aber ich bin sehr gespannt. Das sieht interessant, spannend und gut aus.
Wenn du mit 8 Toren 16 Punkte holst, ist das wert.
Das ist ein guter Quotient, würde ich auch sagen. Aktuell reicht es eben für den zweiten Tabellenplatz. Bei Todi Bo habe ich noch mal kurz nachgeschlagen. Wir kennen ihn natürlich noch von Schalke 04. Da dachte ich mir, da hat er doch gar nicht so eine große Rolle gespielt. Oder ja, nur vier Spiele hat er damals da gemacht. War ja auch nur für eine halbe Serie, glaube ich, da ausgeliehen von Barca. Wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere, ich weiß nicht, Alex, ob du das noch...
Ja, dann haben sie ihn verschenkt, verscherbelt, weil sie nichts mit ihm anfangen konnten. Und man hat aber in den wenigen Einsätzen gesehen, dass er Potenzial hat. Und das entfaltete offenbar jetzt sehr, sehr gut in Frankreich.
War jetzt auch gegen Deutschland im Kader.
Ja, Fehlverkauf von Barca, wie so viele Fehleinschätzungen bei Spielertransfers. Gab es ja einige in der Bartomeo-Ära.
Ich sehe den auch so für 50, 60, 70 Millionen nach England wechseln nächsten Sommer.
Ja, gut, ich meine, wenn er gerade so gut ist. Er ist 23 Jahre alt. Das ist ja das Verrückte. Also der hat vor vier Jahren auf Schalke gespielt und jetzt ist er 23.
Den haben sie mit 18, glaube ich, für eine Million von Toulouse bekommen. Also einer dieser Deals, der sehr schwer vorstellbar ist in der heutigen Zeit. Dass du so früh so einen Rohdiamanten entdeckst und bekommen kannst, für so wenig Geld logischerweise. Wenn man an Ada Güller denkt, der hat ja direkt schon 40 gekostet, in ähnlichem Alter. Also eigentlich ein Monster-Deal, aber sie wussten nichts mit ihm anzufangen.
Ja, so ist das.
Das war halt noch bevor wir alle wussten, dass es sich quasi lohnt, auch den französischen Innenverteidiger Nummer 16, 17, 18 zu kaufen. Und er wird trotzdem noch einer der besten Delikates sein. Das hat sich ja da erst so langsam rauskristallisiert. Also, Nitza, Platz zwei ungeschlagen, unter anderem PSG, besiegt. Das haben vielleicht auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen. Da stand es lange 3-1, dann irgendwie 3-2, aber haben es über die Zeit bekommen. Weil wir ja auch erfahren haben, gute Abwehr. Da sind wir sehr gespannt darauf, was der neue Rene Maric, der italienische Rene Maric, so zu leisten imstande ist.
Ist der in den italienischen Medien eigentlich ein Thema?
Also sicherlich in nerdigeren Publikationen, aber so jetzt auf der Gazette Titelseite oder so habe ich ihn jetzt noch nicht gesehen.
Na gut, vielleicht noch verdient er das vielleicht auch noch nicht.
Wenn sie dann Champions League spielen oder irgendwie so.
Aber dann lass doch Marius, komm, dann lass doch noch dein zweites Thema machen. Aus der Serie A. Und du hast nämlich indirekt schon über das Team gesprochen, dass eines der Teams der Stunde oder vielleicht das Team der Stunde neben Milan?
Neben Milan, Inter. Gut, Inter hat jetzt einmal verloren, aber trotzdem so vom Überraschungsfaktor her vielleicht genau das Team der Stunde, denn von Inter und Milan erwartet man natürlich, dass sie da vorne mit spielen. Die Fiorentina aktuell auf Platz 4 mit 17 Punkten und eben wie gesagt gerade den amtierenden Meister Napoli geschlagen. Und dabei diese Saison ziemlich begeisternden Fußball am Spielen. Italiano gilt seit Jahren als eines der größten Trainertalente in Italien. Und alle haben die Fiorentina beglückwünscht, als sie ihn verpflichten konnten von Spezia. Hat dann ja auch letztes Jahr das Conference League Finale erreicht. In der Liga war es dann aber eigentlich immer so mal hui, mal fui so ein bisschen. Also die Klasse, die das Team oder der Kader da letzte Saison schon hatte, ist nicht konstant genug auf den Platz gebracht worden. Und dass sie diese Saison wieder in der Conference League spielen dürfen, liegt nur daran, dass Juve disqualifiziert wurde. Na gut, aber jetzt sind sie wieder dabei. Und in der Liga läuft es bisher fantastisch. Italiano ist ein ganz moderner Trainer, der auch sehr innenverteidigerlastiges Aufbauspiel betreibt, sehr variabel in der Offensive spielen lässt und ein extremes Angriffspressing praktizieren lässt. Das hat Napoli, wo sie letzte Saison ja immer, egal wer gepresst hat, wie gepresst hat, super rausgekommen sind jetzt gegen Florenz, haben die sich einfach einschnüren lassen. Und deswegen war der Sieg auch komplett folgerichtig, auch in der Höhe am Ende. Und ganz interessant, ich würde das auch unter anderem an der Personalie Nico González festmachen, den Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen ja bestens noch von seiner Zeit beim VfB Stuttgart kennen, der letzte Saison immer mal wieder angeschlagen war. Kleine Wehwechen hat er deswegen ja, meine ich, auch die WM verpasst hat und sich jetzt nicht Weltmeister nennen darf. Der ist die Saison aber komplett fit und hat, glaube ich, wettbewerbsübergreifend schon 8, 9, 10 Tore geschossen und ist auch in der Serie A Torschützenliste hinter Lottaro Martínez und Ozyman aktuell auf dem Podium und, ja, Florenz zugucken. Macht unglaublich Spaß, hat natürlich auch immer mit diesen lilanen Trikots, so Battistuta, Rui Costa und so Baccio, da erinnert man sich irgendwie gern zurück, da schwingt so ziemlich viel Flair mit. Marvin Compea. Also das weckt Emotionen, wenn die dann halt begeisternd in den Fußball spielen und wieder da vorne mitspielen, dann ist natürlich auch ganz logisch, dass da direkt gesagt wird, also jetzt auf jeden Fall, wir können ja versuchen, die Meisterschaft anzugreifen und so, also da die Erwartungen bei den Fans sind auch immer sehr schnell, sehr weit oben. Das muss man dann mal sehen. Aber wenn die Mannschaft nicht wieder so einen Konstanzabfall hat, wie in der letzten Saison, dann ist auf jeden Fall mit denen zu rechnen. Und in der Conference League, da haben sie zwei Mal unentschieden gespielt gegen Genk und Ferenç Varos, aber ich glaube auch, dass sie da die Gruppenphase überstehen werden und dann ja vielleicht, ich habe das Finale gegen Frankfurt gecallt, vor der Saison wäre glaube ich ganz attraktiv.
Ja, schauen wir mal. Da zweifle ich eher an der SGE, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist immer ein schlechtes Zeichen, wenn bei der Auslosung schon gesagt wird, ja, also, Frankfurt könnte den Wettbewerb gewinnen. Hä, bitte was? Das ist ein schlechtes Zeichen mit deutschen Medien, so wie jemand schreiben. Mein Herz geht ja auf, Marius, wenn ich sehe, dass Giacomo Bonaventura da auch gerade anscheinend eine gute Saison spielt.
Vier Tore, zwei Assists.
Ja, der hat ja auch eine unglaubliche Verletzungsgeschichte hinter sich. Sonst hätte der vielleicht eine viel größere Karriere hinlegen können, als er das im Endeffekt gemacht hat. Und er ist auch mit Mitte 30 immer noch das Herz des Spiels. Also, Lieder auf dem Platz, geht voran und erzielt auch immer sehr, sehr viele schöne Tore. Also, er hat halt irgendwie ein Talent dafür, in der Flanke irgendwie den Volley reinzuspringen und da geht er in den Winkel. Also da, ja, das ist so ein Spieler zum Zunge-Schnalzen oder wie man bei Doppel-Sechs gesagt hätte.
Oh ja, allein Giacomo Bonaventura. Es ist ja klar, dass er das hier gut macht. Er heißt ja nicht Mediaventura. Also, Florenz steht sehr gut da. Tabellenplatz 4 aktuell. Und wie besprochen, einiges gibt es da zu sehen. Und dann wollen wir nochmal nach La Liga blicken. Da gibt es auch einiges zu sehen bei Celta Vigo. Aber es betrifft leider Alex häufig die Gegner. Und das macht etwas mit dem Trainer, der heißt nämlich Rafa Benitez.
Was ist los bei Vigo?
So, jetzt habe ich eine Frage an dich zum Einstieg. Wenn Mendilba der spanische Neururer Magath ist, was oder wer oder was ist dann Rafa Benitez?
Oh Gott, es muss ja jemand sein, der einmal was gewonnen hat.
Da wäre ich, glaube ich, bei Magath gewesen.
Ja? Kann man vielleicht gelten lassen.
Vielleicht auch tatsächlich Niko Kovac?
Aber na, nee, da fällt mich nicht.
Der ist ja noch nicht so lange im Game wie Benitez.
Ja, vor allem Benitez hat jetzt einen Stil, den einfach kein deutscher Trainer jemals hatte.
Darf ich nicht vergessen, mit Valencia war er zum Beispiel im Champions League-Finale. Wurde ja auch Meister. Wann war das? Anfang der 2000er, 2001, 2002, 2003, irgendwas. Also, der ist schon sehr, sehr lange dabei. Ja, auf jeden Fall läuft es trotz seiner großen Erfahrung. Er hat natürlich einen sehr, sehr spannenden Job bei Celta übernommen, denn er sollte sie endlich mal umkrempeln, nachdem sie, ich glaube, drei Jahre in Folge im Abstiegskampf waren und immer jeweils bis zum letzten Spieltag zittern mussten und den Klassenverbleib teilweise, ja, wirklich Minuten vor Schluss, diesen erst gerettet oder mit einem Sieg gegen Barca letztes Jahr, weil es für Barca nicht so viel ging. Wenn sie das Spiel nicht gewonnen hätten, hätten sie auch absteigen können. Also, es war wirklich, ja, jeweils sehr, sehr knapp in den letzten Jahren. Und mit Rafa Benitez sollte jemand eben jetzt kommen, der enorme Erfahrung hat, der ja vor vielen Jahren natürlich ein Erfolgscoach war.
Er ist quasi wie Giovanni Trapattoni, als er damals zum VfB gekommen ist.
Das hat dir jetzt keine Ruhe gelassen, ne?
Aber schön, dass wir das VfB erwähnt haben.
Lass ich mal so gelten, wie dem auch sei. Auf jeden Fall, ja, spannende Trainerrolle angenommen, sollte Celta Vigo, du magst der Vergleiche, so etwas wie Werder Bremen, La Liga, so ein bisschen kann man es vergleichen. So, und sollte sie endlich mal wieder nicht nur aus dem Abstiegsraum rausbekommen, sondern optimalerweise die Top Ten annähern. Aber klappt leider nicht so gut wie bisher, denn sie haben erst ein Spiel gewonnen von neun und sind erneut wieder im Abstiegskampf, wieder drittletzter aktuell. Es klappt also einfach überhaupt nicht. Die Frage ist, warum? Die wirst du mir natürlich jetzt stellen. Ich beantworte sie direkt, weil sie einfach ihre Chancen nicht in Tore ummünzen. Also sie spielen wirklich eigentlich ansehentlichen Fußball, auch mutig, also Benitez ist gar nicht so der Maggert vom Fußballstile her, dass du sagst, die Mauern nur stellen sich hinten rein und hoffen, dass der liebe Gott irgendwie was vorne vom Laster fallen lässt. Nee, gegen Barca zum Beispiel haben sie 2-0 in Barcelona geführt und zwar verdient geführt, haben wirklich grandios gespielt. Und dann ging es ab der 80. Schiefe und sie verloren noch 2-3. Also die Gegenteuer waren in der 80., 85., 88. oder so. Sie waren auf Kurs, Sieg und zwar auch verdient, also eine tolle Leistung, auch nicht um Münzen können. Zu Hause gegen Real Madrid haben sie auch eine gute Leistung gezeigt. Ein Tor wurde aberkannt nach Ecke, das eigentlich hätte stehen dürfen sollen müssen. Und dann hinten raus Bellingham, Bellingham-Dinge gemacht nach einer Ecke, 0-1 verloren. Also auch in den beiden Spielen, die ich gesehen habe, ich habe jetzt natürlich nicht jedes Spiel gesehen, gegen die ganz Großen haben sie wirklich gut gespielt, haben dagegen gehalten, mutig. Dann denkst du dir, okay, wenn es gegen die Großen nicht klappt, die ja individuelle Klasse besitzen, solltest du immerhin die Kleinen schlagen können mit dieser Spielweise. Genau das klappt eben nicht. Sie verlieren die Spiele, die sie eigentlich, ja, keinesfalls verlieren dürften, sollten, um nicht zu sagen, die sie eigentlich gewinnen müssten. Also es gab Heimniederlagen, lass mich nachgucken, gegen Mallorca zu Hause in den Abstiegskandidaten, gegen Osasuna zu Hause, ein mittelmäßiges Club, mittelmäßigen Club, und gegen Getafe, auch in den Abstiegskandidaten gab es einen 2 zu 2, so wie gegen Alaves zu Hause auch nur einen 1 zu 1. Also das sind eigentlich die Mannschaften, diese typischen kleinen Teams, die du eigentlich schlagen müsstest, schlagen solltest. Und das kriegen sie einfach nicht hin. Und deswegen stecken sie erneut leider wieder im Abstiegskampf. Und ja, so ein bisschen ist man, glaube ich, schon ratlos, weil man sich mehr erhofft hat.
Aber wackelt da der Stuhl schon, weil man kommt ja an den Chancen nicht vorbei. Also ganz interessant, Zeltavigo, die viertmeisten Schüsse in La Liga, übrigens auf Platz 2 im Sandwich zwischen Real und Barca, Sevilla, über die wir ja auch schon gesprochen haben. Also sprich, man sieht aber quasi, es gibt Chancen, sie werden eben nicht genutzt. Kann man das auch so, ist es dementsprechend auch bewertet dann in La Liga, dass man sagt, naja, das ist wahrscheinlich eine Frage der Zeit, bis sich das dann wieder angleicht?
Das würde ich auch sagen, aber du siehst schon an Sevilla, manchmal verlieren da die handelnden Personen die Nerven. Das droht ihm natürlich auch. Ich bin froh, um ehrlich zu sein, ich habe jetzt nichts mit Zeltas so am Hut, aber natürlich froh, dass die nicht direkt die Nerven jetzt verloren haben. Länder-Schulpause. Aber die nächste kommt ja auch wieder in den Monat. Wer weiß, wie es dann aussieht. Man kennt ja diesen Zeitpunkt aktuell. Ich persönlich finde, und das hast du einen guten Punkt gebracht, dass die underlying Stats zeigen, dass es nicht so schlecht ist, wie die Tabellensituation darliegt. Du hast die Chancen angesprochen. Von den X-Points her müssten sie eigentlich 6 Punkte mehr haben. Also sie haben aktuell 6 Punkte auf dem Konto. Genau. Und von den X-Points her müssten sie eigentlich 12 Punkte oder 13 haben. Also 12,7 ist der Wert. Und mit 12 oder 13 Punkten wärst du ganz genau 9. Und das ist ja so die Tabellenregion, in die sie hoffen, mal klettern zu können. Also du siehst schon daran, sie müssten mehr Punkte haben, sie müssten mehr Tore schießen. Sie spielen also nicht so schlecht, belohnen sich einfach nicht. Und wenn du dich fragst, warum können sie sich nicht belohnen, ich würde daran das an einem Namen festmachen wollen. Das ist ihr Superstar und Thales Maniago Aspas, der seit Jahren der wichtigste, beste Spieler ist, der Kapitän, der Torgarant. Und der hat noch kein einziges Liga-Tor geschossen. Das ist absolut, ja, unerklärlich.
Macht sich das Alter da langsam bemerkbar?
Der ist glaube ich schon 36, ja, offenbar so ein bisschen. Dann schon irgendwann baust du ab. Er hat die letzten 5, 6, 7 Jahre immer 14 oder mehr Tore geschossen. Teilweise auch 20 Tore. Fast immer auch zweistellige Assists gehabt. Also war wirklich mit Abstand der Lebensretter. Selters, ohne ihn wären sie 3x 8 schon abgestiegen. In 3 Saisons in Folge, wenn er nicht regelmäßig seine Tore gemacht hätte. Und in der Saison hat er noch kein einziges Tor geschossen. Und sie sind wieder da unten drin. Und du merkst einfach, wenn er einfach nur 2 oder 3 Törchen hätte, hätten sie wahrscheinlich 6 Punkte mehr. Und dann würden wir anders auch über Rafa Benitez Stuhl reden. Denn am Wochenende, jetzt beim 2-2-igen Retafe, erneut ein täuschendes Spiel, hat er kurz vor Schluss seinen Elfmeter verschossen. Allein das wäre schon der Sieg gewesen.
Da drehste durch als Trainer. Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass Rafa Benitez nicht schon viel gesehen hätte in seiner Karriere. Er ist ja für alle wie... Er ist ja, das ist ja international bekannt, er ist ja quasi der Giovanni Trapattoni Englantz. Jetzt haue ich alles durcheinander, aber ist ja auch egal.
War nur der Trapattoni, der zu dem VfB kam.
Genau, der VfB-Trapattoni, natürlich. Wer erinnert sich nicht noch an den VfB-Trapattoni mit Co-Trainer Lothar Matthäus? War das damals schon? Nee, das war nur in Salzburg, oder?
Marius, wie hieß der Lester-Coach? Den Namen hättest du droppen können. Ranieri, der auch seit 30 Jahren im Game ist, der so viele Vereine hatte, der auch Meister wurde. Das wäre dein Vergleich gewesen. Aber der ist ja kein Deutscher, das passt nicht.
Vor allem hatte der keine Zeit in Deutschland. Für mich findet alles nur in Deutschland statt. Das ist ja klar.
Die berühmte internationale Frage Can he do it against Sandhausen on a Wednesday night?
Die Antwort ist ziemlich sicher nein. Denn eigentlich kann es fast keine in Sandhausen. Nicht mal Sandhausen kann aktuell Sandhausen Dinge tun. Aber das ist ein Thema für eine andere Liga Tour, die vielleicht in der nächsten Woche kommt. Dann wollen wir nochmal in die Ligue 1 gucken. Wir haben schon über Nizza gesprochen. Jetzt wollen wir über Lance sprechen. Was ist denn da erwähnenswert, David?
Ja, wenn man auf die Tabelle schaut, sind sie relativ weit unten. Wobei, na, ich fange mal anders an. Also ich gebe hier mal ein kurzes Recap. Die waren ja überraschend zweiter vergangenen Saison. Das habt ihr ja auch nochmal schön aufgearbeitet in der Liga Tour Saisonfinale. Einziges Champions League-Team neben PSG diese Saison. Konnten auch ihre starke Defensive behalten, inklusive Danzo, über den du dich ja schon gewundert hast, dass der da auch nochmal seinen zweiten Frühling, Sommer, Herbst spielt. Hatten nochmal zwei wichtige Spieler verloren, zwei sehr, sehr wichtige Spieler. Sekou Foufana nach Saudi-Arabien und Louis Hopenda nach Leipzig. Kann man jetzt überlegen, was davon schlimmer ist. Also so als Destination, meine ich. Das tat ihnen aber tatsächlich sehr, sehr weh. Mitte September waren sie vorletzter. Hatten einen Punkt aus vier Spielen. Das begann schon unglaublich blamabel mit einer Nierlage gegen Brest. Da ist jeder Beobachter davon ausgegangen, Brest wird gegen den Abstieg kämpfen. Spoiler alert, that didn't happen. Also Brest ist aktuell auf Platz 4. Da müssen wir vielleicht auch mal irgendwann, wenn die da oben bleiben. VfB Stuttgart, Frankreich. Und dann hatten sie sehr, sehr hartes Auftaktprogramm. Also der Spielplan war nicht erfreunt. Rennes, PSG, Monaco, da waren sie dann wieder eher Köln, Frankreichs, die haben ja auch Spielplanpech. Also das war jedenfalls nicht das, was sie... Sie sind nicht eines der traditionellen großen Teams der Liga. Sie haben eine Meisterschaft in der 90er. Aber es ist schon klar, dass sie jetzt nicht eines der top, top Teams sind. Trotzdem war das nicht ihr Anspruch. Die hatten schon formuliert, sie wollen sich im ersten Drittel der Liga etablieren, obwohl sie weniger Budget haben als sieben andere Clubs. Aber der Transfer-Sommer war extrem, extrem chaotisch. Die hatten Wahi eingekauft für 30 Millionen als Rekordeinkauf, hatten eben wie gesagt auch diese 75 Millionen eingenommen für Fofana und Lopenda und haben plötzlich festgestellt, oh Wunder, die Preise sind in die Höhe gegangen, wenn du irgendwo anklopst. Ach was, ihr habt 45 Millionen auf dem Konto. Sie hatten Spearings geholt, der sollte Fofana ersetzen, der verließ den Klub schon im September wieder, weil er sich nicht wohlgefühlt hat. Das war relativ überraschend, dann mussten sie da nochmal kurzfristig Ersatz holen, hatten eine ganze Menge so an Last-Minute-Transfers, Aguilar, Mawassa. Die haben mittlerweile auch Konsequenzen rausgezogen, also die haben ihr Management umstrukturiert und weil sie offenbar auch der Meinung sind, das war jetzt nicht so die Glanzleistung, wie wir da im Sommer aufgetreten sind auf dem Transfermarkt. Und jetzt so langsam haben sie eine Aufwärtskurve. Sie haben jetzt Siege gegen Toulouse in Straßburg gemacht und sie haben dieses überraschende, glorreiche 2 zu 1 gegen Arsenal. In der Champions League, das ich ehrlich gesagt nicht gesehen habe, ich habe mir die Zusammenfassung angeschaut, das sah schon recht cool aus. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich jemand von euch gesehen hat. Also, frühes Gegentor auch noch nach Fehler von Thomas Saint und der macht das aber mit dem 1 zu 1 wieder gut. Das war echt ein Hammer da wieder, der ins Tor gezwirbelt hat. Starke Paraden auch von Brice Samba, der war ja vergangenen Saison schon extrem wichtig. Und Wahi scheint auch jetzt einzuschlagen langsam. Der hat jetzt vier Tore in den letzten drei Spielen. Der wurde ja auch von der Eintracht umworben. Die sind ja immer noch ein bisschen traurig, offenbar, dass sie den nicht bekommen haben. Mal schauen, also leichter Aufwärtstrend bei Lens. Und ja, in der Champions League Gruppe, die führen sie jetzt an vor Arsenal und Sevilla.
Gegen Sevilla gab es ja das 1 zu 1, das angesprochene. Und auch da war der Punktgewinn mindestens verdient, wenn nicht sogar der Dreier verdient gewesen. Und auch gegen Arsenal, was ich so mitbekommen habe, war das alles andere als unverdient. Also bemerkenswerte Leistungen in der Champions League. Hätte ich ihnen so nicht zugetraut, muss ich sagen.
Ich auch nicht. Ich habe noch ein kleines Quiz für euch mitgebracht. Ich hatte es im Vorfeld schon in der WhatsApp-Gruppe geschrieben, ob ihr wisst, ob bei euch schon mal ein usbekischer Spieler gespielt hat in der Liga. Weil mit Abdulkoh Dirk Husanov spielt ein 19-jähriger Innenverteidiger bei Lens jetzt in der... Der kommt aus Usbekistan. Der hat eine... Ich mache erst mal die Frage. Habt ihr schon mal Usbeken gesehen? Weil er ist tatsächlich der erste Liga, stand in den Medien, es ist der erste Usbeke in der Liga, in der Geschichte der Liga.
Es gab bei Juve mal Ilja Zeytulayev, der in der zweiten Mannschaft gespielt hat und dann so ein, zwei Joker-Einsätze bekommen hat. Und aktuell Ilja Shomorodov, der von der Roma an Kaljeri ausgeliehen ist und auch schon bei Genoa und Spezia, glaube ich, gespielt hat.
Wahnsinnswissen.
Hast du das gegoogelt oder wusstest du das, Marius?
Ich musste einmal gucken, ob er wirklich Usbeke ist, aber...
Ich habe es nicht gegoogelt und deswegen kann ich es nicht beantworten. Ich würde eher sagen nein bezüglich La Liga. Aber ich habe es nicht nachgeguckt. Aus dem Stehgreif würde ich eher sagen, schwer vorzustellen.
Gut, er ist jedenfalls 90 Jahre alt, spricht nur usbekisch und russisch, macht die Sache nicht umgängig einfacher. Trainer Frank Aziz ist aber sehr beeindruckt, wie weit er schon in seinem Alter sei. Er kann auf Französisch nur vier Worte, die seien aber für einen Verteidiger ausreichend. Nächstes Quiz, was glaubt ihr, was sind die vier Worte, die Kuzano von Verteidiger?
Ich, du, Tor und hey, Schiri, das war doch faul.
Es ist ein bisschen Verteidiger-spezifisch. Es ist Vasile dorthin, Savien, also kommt, Ball kommt, Avance nach vorne und Seul alleine. Das sind die vier Worte, die ein Verteidiger wissen muss.
Ich habe übrigens nachgeguckt. In La Liga hat noch kein Usbeke gespielt. Sonst hätte ich es sehr gewusst, Max. Aber das ist ja schön, dass man mit vier Worten schon dahin kommt. Das können wir uns ja auch mal merken für alle anderen Verteidiger, die aus die Fremdsprache in die Liga wechseln und dann sagen, na, die brauchen nur Zeit, sich anzupassen. Da können wir immer sagen, mach es doch wie der Usbeke von Lens. Ich habe den Namen, genau, danke.
Ich wollte nicht so respektlos sein.
Der Stark. Also, Lens, das gucken wir uns genau an. Auch in der Champions League. Und schauen uns mal an, ob man es vielleicht wieder schafft, ein bisschen nach oben den Anschluss zu bekommen. Sieben Punkte Rückstand sind es aktuell auf die internationalen Plätze. Saison ist aber natürlich auch noch jung. Und das ist ja eigentlich auch schon eine ganz gute Überleitung. Wir haben noch zwei Themen. Einmal die Awards und einmal die Matches to Watch. Aber ich würde fast sagen, dass doch mit dem Matches to Watch dann anfangen. Was gibt es denn, David, in der Ligue 1, was man sich am nächsten Wochenende einverleiben sollte?
Also am nächsten gibt es erstmal nichts, weil ja Länderspielpause ist. Am nächsten Spieltag genau. Am nächsten Spieltag drauf ist am Samstag Nitsa Marseille. Das ist natürlich absolut großartig. So als Côte d'Azur-Derby und in der Form, in der Nitsa aktuell ist. Am Sonntag kann man sich Monaco gegen Metz anschauen, wenn man den Spitzenreiter sehen will. Da sage ich gleich bei den Awards noch was kurz zu. Und Sonntagabends, wer also richtig schön Katastrophentourismus haben möchte, kann sich Lyon gegen Clermont anschauen. Da spielt er 17. gegen 18.
Ja, aber wirklich, stimmt. Schafft es Lyon, schafft es einer von beiden, seinen ersten Sieg in diese Saison zu bekommen. Ich tippe hart auf 0 zu 0. Ja, das ist doch super. Dann kommt, dann machen wir das schnell gleich durch. Alex, was sind denn die Matches to watch in La Liga?
Wir blicken natürlich auf die Spiele der Trainer und Mannschaften, die wir gerade besprochen haben. Denn du hast eins, glaube ich, sogar schon vorwärts genommen. Der FC Sevilla spielt Just gegen Real Madrid, den Tabellenführer zu Hause. Also das ist natürlich mit dem neuen Coach dann Alonso ein Match to watch und natürlich auch unabhängig vom Trainername und vom Trainerwechsel ein Kracher im spanischen Fußball. Und dann haben wir die andere Mannschaft, die wir heute besprochen haben, Celta Vigo mit Benitez. Die empfangen Atletico Madrid, die sind auch nicht so schlecht unterwegs, sind auch aktuell ganz gut drauf. Also das sind schon mal zwei Spiele to watch. Und das dritte, das ich mitgebe, ist auch ein absoluter Klassiker. Barca gegen den Athletic Club aus Bilbao. Zwei Urgesteine des spanischen Fußballs. Also durchaus drei spannende Spiele am nächsten Spieltag.
Aber wirklich, und dazu der Hinweis, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich schreib das jetzt immer in die Show-Notes rein, mit Anpfiff, Zeit und Datum. Dann findet ihr das auch schneller.
Das ist ein Service.
Ich hab auch extra nachgeschaut, wie immer. Das sind auch tatsächlich Spiele, die im deutschen Fernsehen übertragen werden.
David ist mein Name.
Warum auch immer die sich Lyon gegen Clément, aber gut.
Das war wahrscheinlich auch verzweifelt. Wir brauchen noch irgendwas abends. Komm, dann nehmen wir die Liga. Was haben wir in der Serie A, was wir uns angucken sollten?
Ich würde empfehlen, einfach den Sonntag ab Mittags auf der Couch zu verbringen. Und ab 12.30 Uhr bis 23 Uhr Serie A zu gucken. Vielleicht muss es nicht ganz so früh sein. Roma gegen Monza. Wenn man Mourinho mag, dann kann man sich das sicherlich geben. Aber eigentlich ab 15 Uhr Bologna-Frosinone. Das komme ich gleich bei den Awards zu. Das könnte ein ganz unterhaltsames Spielchen werden. Und dann hat man 18 Uhr Atalanta gegen Genoa. Da bin ich mir sehr sicher, dass das ein sehr unterhaltsames Spiel werden wird. Denn das sind zwei Mannschaften, die offensiv zu einigen im Stande sind. Atalanta ist bekannt und Genoa ein Aufsteiger, der gerne spektakulär spielt. Und dann hat man um 20.45 Uhr das Topspiel Milan gegen Juve. Da kann es sein, dass es spielerisch nicht mega begeisternd wird, aber San Siro wird sicherlich brennen.
Ja, und es ist der aktuelle Tabellenführer. Ich sehe schon Leute, wenn ihr die Hausaufgaben durchhört oder durchschaut, die ihr hier gerade aufbekommt, habt ihr mehr Spiele gesehen als ich an einem normalen Bundesliga-Wochenende. Da wünsche ich euch viel Spaß an der Stelle schon mal. Dann wollen wir aber noch kurz die Awards vergeben. Ihr habt es ja auch schon ein bisschen angeteasert, Majus, wenn du jetzt eh schon gerade mit dabei warst. Du hast Frau Sinone mit dabei. Wir haben ja die drei Kategorien MVP, Unsung Hero und Momente der letzten Spieltage. In welchem Lande denn Frau Sinone dann bei dir?
Beim Unsung Hero. Und da schließt sich dann auch sozusagen der Kreis in der Folge. Denn das ist mal wieder der Trainer, Iosebio Di Francesco, den auch Asche über meinen Haupt und über Marios Haupt bei Serie A, da haben wir so ein bisschen vor der Saison gewitzelt. Ja, wann wird er denn entlassen? Denn seine letzten Stationen, man kennt ihn vielleicht noch von der Roma, da hat er das Champions League Cup-Finale erreicht und danach war bei Sampdoria 8 Spiele mit 0,75 Punkten pro Schnitt, bei Calieri immerhin bis Ende Februar 0,81 Punkte im Schnitt und dann bei Hellas Verona 2021 hat das Ganze 4 Spiele durchgehalten. Man dachte eigentlich, die Karriere wäre schon vorbei. Dann ist aber Frosinona als Meister aufgestiegen und Fabio Grosso, der jetzt das Himmelfahrtskommando in Lyon übernommen hat, hat sich nicht mit dem Verein auf eine Vertragsverlängerung einnehmen können. Dann haben sie sich für die Francesco entschieden und stand jetzt, steht Frosinone mit einem völlig umgekrempelten Kader auf Platz 8. Viele junge Spieler spielen durchaus attraktiven Offensivfußball. Dafür war die Francesco eigentlich schon immer bekannt. Und dass er jetzt steigt so ein bisschen aus der Asche heraus und bekommt wieder mehr Anerkennung, das finde ich schön.
Mir brennen so viele Vergleiche auf der Zunge, aber es war schon genug Bundesliga-Hintergrund. Ich will sie hören, mich hast du damit gequält. Leute, schon abgeschriebene Trainer, die dann jemanden noch mal nach oben führen kurzzeitig und die ganz schlechte Bilanzen vorher hatten, das ist zu einfach. Das wissen auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer selber. Alex, wer ist dein Ansang-Hero?
Darf ich das eigentlich in einem Abwasch machen? Ansang-Hero, MVP, da ist die Frage des Spieltags oder der Saison. Der Saison ist klar, wir hatten es vor zwei Folgen. Das ist einfach Bellingham und der muss auch weiter Saison-MVP bleiben. Hat jetzt wieder einen Doppelpack am Wochenende gemacht, ist in der Torjägerliste auf Platz 1 mit 8 Toren in 8 Spielen. Absolut bemerkenswert nicht nur die Zahl an sich, sondern er trifft alle 84 Minuten. Das sind ja fast schon Lewandowski-Harland-Nummern. Also absolut bemerkenswert der herausragende Spieler der Saison bisher in Spanien, kurz und bündig gemacht.
Bessere Werte als Ronaldo in seinen ersten 8 Spielen.
Tatsächlich. Welcher Ronaldo? Christian. Der berühmte oder der andere?
Der andere.
Der ist natürlich auch berühmt, das ist schon klar. Aber Bellingham, das haben wir ja schon abgefrühstückt. Wen würdest du denn als Alternativ-MWP vorstellen?
Deswegen wollte ich ja sagen, das ist jetzt eher langweilig. Den kennen wir alle. Ein anderer MVP des Spieltags oder an St. Hero wäre Brian Saragossa. Der hat nämlich Barca abgeschossen. Es war am Ende nur ein 2 zu 2 von Granada, aber ein absoluter Punkt Gewinn für die Analysen, die ja auch ganz unten drin stehen. Und die Tore waren bemerkenswert. Das erste Tor hat danach, ich glaube, 15 Sekunden geschossen, direkt nach dem Ampfiff. Also wirklich kalte Dusche für Barca. Und das zweite Tor, wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, sollte es sich anschauen. Da bricht er wieder über links durch. Also er ist ein Flügelspieler, vernascht Kunde, vernascht Ter Stegen mit einer Körperdrehung und schießt ihn dann mit dem Außenrist hoch ins Tor. Also wirklich ein tolles Tor, vielleicht das Tor des Spieltags. Bemerkenswertes Resultat, Doppelpack gegen Barca. Und direkt auch, deswegen ist er gar nicht so ansang, er wurde in die spanische Nationalmannschaft nominiert. Direkt nach seinem Doppelpack. Also ein Name, den man sicherlich hier im Podcast noch nicht gehört hat, auch generell in Deutschland noch nicht so häufig. Er spielt halt nur bei Granada, aber ein trickreicher, vor Selbstbewusstsein strotzender Flügelspieler, den kann man ja nur mögen. Und wenn er dann zwei gegen Barca macht, ist er der Hero des Spieltags für mich.
Und das ist jetzt dann quasi auch gleichzeitig dein Ansagen Hero und dein Moment des Spieltags, habe ich das richtig verstanden.
Genau, so kann man es zusammenfassen.
Na, da hat sich ja jemand leicht gemacht. Aber gut.
Aber es passt halt einfach gut.
Seid ihr doch verziehen. Ich stichel doch nur und dementsprechend gehe ich schon mal in Position für den Ansagen Hero in der Ligue 1.
Du hast jetzt gerade Bewegung gemacht für Kinder geboren?
Nee, ich habe eigentlich versucht, so stichel ich. Aber da sieht man mal, wie ich...
Ach so, ja.
Ich dachte, es gräbt irgendwas aus.
Ich dachte, es wäre dieses, was die Spieler machen würden. Also liebe Podcast-Hörer, ihr könnt das jetzt nicht sehen, weil wir sind ja jetzt im Video.
Es sah offenbar aus, als hätte ich ein Kind gewogen.
Ein Kind gewogen, ja. Aber das passt ja nicht ganz so schlecht, weil ich bin ja Ligue 1 und ihr erwartet ja von mir, dass ich euch die jungen, jungen Talente präsentiere, von denen man in mehreren Jahren dann spricht. Weil genau so einen habe ich als Anzang Hero dabei. Solange er noch Anzang ist, hat sich jetzt am Wochenende schon fast wieder gewandelt. Eli Junior Crupi. 17 Jahre bei Lorient, kam in den vergangenen 7 Spielen für Lorient zum Einsatz, 5 Torbeteiligungen. 2 davon gegen Lyon am Wochenende. Teamkollege Bakayoko, der jetzt bei Lorient gelandet ist, hat gesagt, dass Crupi ihn an einen jungen Mbappé erinnere. Bakayoko muss es wissen, denn er hat mit Mbappé in der Meistermannschaft von Monaco gekickt. Ihr habt es zuerst gehört.
Im offensiven Mittelfeld, ist das richtig? Also keine Stürme? Na, da kennt man ja aber auch gar keine Vereine, die da suchen.
Max, darf ich dein Wigen-Dingsbums-Symbolzeichen aufgreifen? Ich habe nämlich einen Unsung-Hero, ist er nicht, aber schon ein kleinen Hero, nämlich geschichtsträchtigen Hero, fast unter den Tisch fallen lassen. Vergessen, Lamine Jamal, der Barca-Superstar im Upcoming, mit 16 Jahren, der jüngste Torschütze La Liga geworden beim 2. Tor gegen Granada. Hätte ich fast unter den Tisch fallen lassen. Ist natürlich bemerkenswert. Der ist nicht Unsung. Man hat ihn mittlerweile besungen, natürlich, weil er der Shootingstar schlechthin ist. Aber das erste Mal eben getroffen jetzt gegen Granada. Und mit, lass mich nachgucken, 16 Jahre und 87 Tagen, jüngste Torschütze in der Geschichte der Primärer Division. Genau, hat einen langfristigen Vertrag bekommen. Ist natürlich schon Nationalspieler. Hat auch bei der Nationalmannschaft schon getroffen, wie man es halt mit 16 Jahren so macht. Also absolut bemerkenswert. Hat jetzt nicht ganz, ich habe zu starkköpfig in diese Kategorien gedacht, nicht ganz in das Unsung Hero Kategorie gepasst, weil man ihn einfach schon kennt. Aber allein dieser Rekord, das wäre töricht, wenn ich den hier nicht erwähne, ne?
Ja, absolut. Töricht ist da auch genau das Attektiv, was mir eigentlich gefallen wäre. Marius, dann machen wir noch MVP und Momente Spieltags.
Ist eigentlich beides relativ offensichtlich. Dafür MVP Lau Toro Martínez. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, der wurde mir vorgelegt. Ich komme eigentlich meistens nicht.
Aber bitte sag mir, dass man das in italienischen Medien nicht wirklich auch macht.
Also sein Spitzname ist der Toro, das übersetzt sich dann natürlich nicht so gut. Aber ich habe den, also es gibt der Rete Gi bei Napoli und Rete ist das Tor. Ich habe das noch nicht gelesen. Und eigentlich ist das so offensichtlich. Aber vielleicht habe ich es auch einfach ausgeblendet.
Nee, ich glaube, dafür haben italienische Vereine zu viel Stil. Diese Lewandowski-Nummer usw., das machen halt deutsche Vereine.
Ja, Martinez, 10 Tore in 8 Spielen, Viererpack gegen das Hellenitana, trägt Inter nach den Abgängen von Lukaku und Dzeku quasi allein auf seinen Schultern. Mit Markus Thüram übrigens, Superduo. Thüram glänzt als Vorbereiter meistens, hat schon 7 Assists und Martinez verwandelt halt und auch aus jeder Lage. Ja, das, was er bei der WM für Argentinien verschossen hat, das holt er jetzt irgendwie nach und das finde ich schon sehr beeindruckend. Und der Moment des Spieltags, der gebührt Olivier Giroud, natürlich, wir haben ihn den sexiest goalkeeper alive genannt.
Warum freut sich David da so sehr?
Ja, weil es auch in den französischen Medien eine unglaublich große Story war. Es kamen jetzt auch noch Sachen, ich weiß gar nicht, hat man das in Deutschland mitbekommen? Es war ja der unglaubliche insgesamt so.
Ich glaube schon, dass das in den deutschen Medien schon überall aufgegriffen wurde.
Ja, es war aber nur so eine kleine... Also ich habe es mitbekommen. War das jetzt im Spiel gegen Genoa, wo er ins Tor musste? Also eben für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die es nicht mitbekommen haben. Mignon sieht rot und weil das Auswechselkontingent schon ausgeschöpft ist, streift sich Olivier Giroud. Die Torhüterhandschuhe über, geht ins Tor für sogar durchaus noch ein paar Minuten. Das war ja dann... Und ich glaube, er musste auch hin und wieder eingreifen.
Er hat eine richtige Parade, wo er so mit dem Arm nach vorne geht. Da gibt es jetzt auch ein kleines Video, weil die Nationalmannschaft zusammengekommen ist, wo er mit den Trainern steht und dann ihnen erzählt, dass er da einen blauen Fleck hat von der ganzen Nation. Und Guy Stéphane, der eine Co-Trainer, sagt dann, ja, aber weißt du, was ich besonders beeindruckt von dir fand, war, wie du mit den Augen nach einer Ecke geschaut hast. Und da hat man gemerkt, dass du richtig... Und ich hab jetzt auch gehört, anscheinend hat der Verein ja jetzt auch das Trikot von Giroud in den Online-Shop gestellt, also als Torhütertrikot.
Obwohl er nicht mal daraus Kapitalschlangen ist, ja klar.
Wurde er nicht von der Serie A in die Mannschaft des Spieltags als Torhüter gewählt oder war das...
Ich glaube, zumindest in irgendeinem, irgendwo auch, ja, hab ich auch schon das gesehen.
Also, kleines Gmbick, ne?
Der Jan Koller oder Michael Thanat, der Serie A.
Ich erinnere mich, daran erinnern sich die Älteren.
Ich hab bei Transfermarkt so eine Umfrage-Grafik gebaut mit wer hat's am besten gemacht und ich hab mich nicht an Michael Thanat erinnert.
Dabei hat er sogar noch einen Schuss, der dann abgepfiffen war, aber den hat er aus dem Eck rausgeholt.
Vielleicht ist er zu jung, der arme Marius. Einen Verziehen.
Nee, ich hab das damals schon gesehen, aber kam nicht.
Es sei dir verziehen. Also Olivier Giroud zwischen den Pfosten vom AC Milan. Das ist ein sehr schöner Moment des Spieltags. Ich hatte ihn nämlich schon wieder vergessen. Danke, dass das wieder herauskommt.
Im wahrsten Sinne ein schöner Moment.
Aber wir wollen ja nicht so oberflächlich sein. Weder bei Frauen noch bei Männern. In der Ligue 1, was haben wir denn da noch offen, David? Wenn ich es richtig sehe, MVP und Moment.
Der Moment wird allerdings nicht so schön. Ich überlege jetzt gerade, ob ich das vorziehe, damit wir nicht auf so einem Downer enden. Also im Moment, außergewöhnlicher Moment des Spieltags, hat sich beim Spiel Montpellier gegen Clément ereignet. Montpellier hatte einen vergleichsweise okayen Saisonstart. Die stehen aber, wenn ihr auf die Tabelle schaut, aktuell mit einem Spiel weniger da. Weil das Spiel wurde abgebrochen. Die haben 4 zu 2 geführt. Die haben sich zurückgekämpft wieder. Die standen sogar noch mit 10 Mann auf dem Feld. Und es läuft hier Nachspielzeit. Und es sieht alles danach aus, als ob das ein ganz großartiger Abend für Montpellier ist, die sich noch auf die Schulter klopfen können. Und da sagen können, super, haben wir geschafft. Und dann wirft ein Fan einen Böller, und zwar einen ziemlich großen, Clémence Torwart Murray Dior, vor die Füße. Und zwar wirklich vor die Füße. Und der explodiert, der kippt zusammen, muss auf der Trage weggebracht werden. Was schön ist, ist, dass die Ultras tatsächlich direkt, da kann man auf den Bildern auch sehen, in eine Richtung zeigen. Also auf den Mann zeigen. Der wurde auch verhaftet mittlerweile. Der gehört anscheinend auch keiner Ultra-Gruppierung an. Sei angeblich zu betrunken gewesen, um ihn zu verhören an dem Tag. Ja, aber es steht zu befürchten, dass A Montpellier nicht nur dieses Spiel, das sie sich da erkämpft haben, verlieren wird, sondern dass sie auch noch mit Punktabzug bestraft werden, weil in einem ähnlichen Fall als ein Böller mal in Richtung Spieler geflogen ist. Ich glaube, bei Metz war das. Da gab es auch zwei Punkte Abzug. Das ist der Präsident Nicolas, der Junge, also nicht der aus der Meistermannschaft damals, hat auch bereits sich sehr deutlich vor die Kameras gestellt und mehr oder weniger gesagt, das ist ein Arschloch.
Wie geht es dem Torhüter?
Der scheint wieder in Ordnung zu sein. Ich glaube, der ist sogar zum Nationalteam abgereist. Ich meine, ich was gehört zu haben.
Verwechselst du es jetzt nicht mit Olivier Giroud?
Nein.
Sorry, der lag zu nahe.
Ja, der war klar. Ich muss kurz schauen. Ist ja auch egal. Aber es geht ihm definitiv besser.
Genau, darum geht es. Das ist ja auch sehr gut. Dann schauen wir, was da bei Montpellier passiert. Das wiederum habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Danke, David. Und wer ist denn dann der MVP aktuell?
Senegal ist er übrigens. Er ist Torhüter des Senegalen. Im Nationalteam. Mein MVP ist, das habe ich vorhin schon kurz geteasert, kommt aus der Monaco-Mannschaft. Das ist Ismael Jacobs. Der ist der Bundesliga-Ismael Jacobs.
Ex-Kölner, oder?
Falls du Vergleiche haben möchtest. Genau, Ex-Kölner. Er hat ein Tor, eine Vorlage beigesteuert beim 3-1 gegen eine durchaus überzeugende Mannschaft aus Reims. Die muss das sehr, sehr, glaube ich, geärgert haben, dass Balogun, der vergangene Saison an sie ausgeliehen war, von Arsenal, hatte ich berichtet hier in der Liga Tour. Der spielt ja jetzt bei Monaco, hat gegen sie jetzt geknipst. Und Monaco ist einfach nach wie vor bernstark unter Bällenführer. Und Ismael Jakobs ist eigentlich gar nicht Stammspieler aktuell. Der durfte mal von Anfang an ran. Das heißt, Adi Hütte hat auch noch, hat nicht nur eine geile Mannschaft zurzeit, sondern auch noch Auswahl. Das sieht schon richtig gut aus. Und deswegen ja auch mein Hinweis könnte Spaß machen da am nächsten Spieltag, die mal zu sehen. Hab 21 Tore schon geschossen, ein Tor weniger als der VfB.
Also ich muss sagen, diese Worts, die machen mir unheimliche Freude, dass wir hier über Ismael Jakobs sprechen. Und ich habe das gar nicht mitbekommen. Also richtig, richtig cool. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt für eine, wie immer, sehr schöne Runde. Und danke, dass ihr mir immer alle Bundesliga-Quervergleiche, sollten sie noch so schief sein, durchgehen lasst. Ganz herzlichen Dank an David Franchet de Pont-Lévin von 93. Danke dir, lieber David. Danke an Alex Treuker von vivalaliga.de unter anderem. Danke, lieber Alex.
Sehr gerne.
Und danke an Marius Seucke von Serie Amore. Wann startest du dein Portal, Marius? Das ist die einzige Frage. Danke, dass du mit dabei warst.
Vielen Dank auch für die Einladung.
Und wir machen jetzt hier weiter mit der Premier League. Hallo, Jogi Hebel. Schön, dass du da bist für die Premier League.
Danke für die Einladung.
Ja, wir wollen jetzt sprechen über die wichtigsten Themen aus der Premier League. Und wir küren natürlich noch die Awards und die Matches to Watch. Ein paar Ligen haben wir ja schon hinter uns. Jetzt geht es nach England. Mit was willst du denn anfangen? Du hast uns Arsenal gegen City und Liverpool gegen Brighton mitgebracht.
Ja, darfst du dir aussuchen. Das kleinere Thema, oder das wahrscheinlich kontroversere wäre jetzt erst mal Liverpool, weil es da eine Vorgeschichte gibt mit Jürgen Klopp. Wenn du dich daran erinnerst. Ich glaube, ich fange damit einfach mal an. Das haben wir im Podcast auch so gemacht tatsächlich. Ich finde das sehr witzig. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das Spiel gesehen hast, aber es gibt zwei kuriose Situationen. Einmal Elfmeter, den Liverpool bekommt. Dann gibt es viele, die sagen, Doppelbestrafung hätte eigentlich hergemusst, weil klare Torchance verhindert. Da war dann sehr witzig, dass Jürgen Klopp auf der Pressekonferenz danach gefragt worden ist. Er meinte, er habe auch gehört, dass das so ist. Wer ist denn dafür? Dann haben fünf Journalisten schon mal die Hand gehoben. Da gibt es schon Leute, die das irgendwie erharten. Und dann, als er fünf Sekunden später gefragt worden ist, auf der anderen Seite gab es einen Handelfmeter. Wird schon von Daik. Was war denn da los? Ja, Handelfmeter. Ach, das meinte die Zerbi, als er mich da so anschrie. Er hat irgendwas von Penalty gerufen. Ja, habe ich nicht mitbekommen. Das hat er dann logischerweise nicht mitbekommen. Und das ist halt schon irgendwie witzig gewesen. Musste ich sehr schmunzeln, weil das halt Jürgen Klopp einfach eines Bestes in seiner momentanigen Rolle ist.
Aber was war denn die Vorgeschichte jetzt zu Liverpool? Also meinst du mit der Vorgeschichte jetzt quasi der fälschlich aberkannte Treffen?
Dass das momentan einfach in aller Munde ist bei ihm. Wir haben im Podcast auch darüber philosophiert. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, wenn er zuvor diesen Ermittler nicht bekommen hätte, und wenn das nicht schon schrittlich gewesen wäre, dann hätte er richtig vom Leder gelassen. Aber so ist das Spiel unentschieden ausgegangen. Er konnte jetzt nicht so, sonst wäre er endgültig durchgedreht. Weil er hat schon Backlash bekommen in England. Logischerweise sind 19 von 20 Fanlagern gegen Liverpool. Da ruft er schnell mal so, dass er immer kloppt. Deswegen hat es auch nicht leicht. Er hat recht, aber du kennst ihn ja auch. Er macht es immer ein bisschen laut.
Wie ist das sportlich zu bewerten? Brighton ist ja ein Überraschungsteam. Aktuell 16 Punkte, 6. Platz. Liverpool mit 17 Punkten, nur einen davor. Aber man hat noch den Anschluss zur Spitze. Drei Punkte Rückstand auf die Tabellenführer. Wer das ist, lasse ich gleich noch raus. Und jetzt eben dieses 2 zu 2. War das auch leistungsgerecht? Absolut.
Und es zeigt bei beiden Mannschaften Stärken und Schwächen. Dass Brighton mit allen mitspielen kann, ist respektabel. Dass es funktioniert, ist respektabel. Hat die Woche davor nicht funktioniert, aber jetzt funktioniert es wieder. Das zeigt, dass sie immer in einem Spiel eine Chance haben. Ich habe nachgeschaut vorher noch mal, Expected Goals auf beiden Seiten 2,3 zu 2,4 oder so. Das sagt ja auch eine Menge aus. Liverpool ist nach wie vor nicht so stabil hinten, wie sie es gerne hätten. Brighton kann jeden Gegner nerven. Jetzt kannst du dir aussuchen, was von beiden schöner ist. Liverpool ist immer für 2 Tore gut, aber das Problem ist, sie sind vorne wie hinten.
Was hat damit der Umbruch zu tun? Wir haben schon mal darüber gesprochen, dass Liverpool das Mittelfeld umgestellt hat. Das sieht man ja, wenn man sich die Ausstollerung anguckt. In dem Spiel waren es jetzt wieder Sorbislaimek, Alistair und Elliott. Wir haben das ja schon thematisiert. Hängt damit dann auch diese defensive Schwäche zusammen, dass man manchmal ein Tor zu viel kassiert?
Das ist die Frage. Das war ja letztes Jahr schon so. Das ist das große Problem, dass es letztes Jahr schon so war. Und dass die Abwehr fast unangetastet ist. Sie haben versucht, mit Trent Alexander-Arnold eher invers zu spielen, um dort vielleicht mehr den Gegner aufhalten zu können. Mehr in der Restverteidigung zu haben. Hat auch nicht funktioniert. Ich bin ehrlich gesagt auch skeptisch. Vor allem, ich habe das in der Vorbereitung schon gesehen. Das ist immer noch so. Bälle zwischen Innenverteidiger und Außenverteidiger. Die gehen fast wie ein Messer durch Butter. Also wirklich. Da haben sie so Probleme, das zu verteidigen. Und auch gerade, wenn es im Tempo gegen Sturz schnell geht, haben die so große Probleme, das zu verteidigen. Und es ist immer so ein Fehler da drinnen, wo du dir sagst, okay, die Innenverteidiger sind nicht mehr so dynamisch, wie sie es mal waren. Und das ist das große Problem. Also sie haben ja angefangen, das ist ja ganz witzig, die Entwicklung, sie haben angefangen, die Abwehr umzubauen, dass diese Verletzungsprobleme in der Abwehr waren vor drei Jahren in der Corona-Saison. Dann haben sie angefangen, jetzt die Offensive umzubauen, mit Rackbo, mit David Nunes, mit Jota, mit Diaz und so. Und jetzt war eigentlich das Mittelfeld dran. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, danach wäre man eigentlich fertig. Aber jetzt geht es hinten wieder los.
Und Alisson Becker sah jetzt nicht immer gut aus in dem Spiel gegen Brighton, oder?
Ja, ich mag den sehr gerne. Jürgen Klopp sagt ja immer, ich habe letztens das Zitat gelesen, Alisson hat uns den Popo gerettet. Das stimmt wirklich, das tut er sehr, sehr häufig. Der kriegt so viel um die Ohren, dass er auch einmal daneben langt. Aber dem würde ich jetzt nicht die große Schuld geben. Die lassen den schon sehr oft alleine. Das muss man schon sagen.
Und auf der anderen Seite, der Serbi ist in aller Munde. Also Brighton dementsprechend ja auch. Es überrascht einen jetzt ja nicht mehr, dass Brighton so gut mithalten kann. Und man weiß ja inzwischen auch schon, was man bekommt. Also Brighton-Spiele lohnen sich immer anzugucken. Ich glaube, das ist so eine einfache Faustregel, die aktuell gilt. Hat sich da nochmal was verändert bei Brighton? Wird den jetzt vielleicht auch anders begegnet von den Gegnern? Eigentlich würde man ja erwarten, dass jetzt dann im zweiten, dritten Jahr, wo man so erfolgreichen Fußball spielt, die Gegner vielleicht auch ein bisschen anders spielen gegen Brighton.
Ja, es gibt so ein paar. Ich glaube zum Beispiel Aston Villa hat es ja letzte Woche sehr, sehr clever gemacht. Die haben halt wirklich einfach, ich sage es mal wieder, Una Emery ist für mich einer der besten Matchplan-Trainer der Welt, wenn nicht sogar für mich der Beste, weil der einfach genau hergeht und sagt, ihr habt das, dann nehmen wir euch weg und wir finden schon einen Weg. Und das ist einfach das Pragmatischste wahrscheinlich gegen die, weil dann nimmst du es ihnen wirklich. Und Liverpool spielt natürlich mit. Die denken sich, wir sind Liverpool und die werden natürlich ein paar Dinge anpassen, aber im Grunde genommen wollen die schon nach vorne spielen, weil sonst nimmst du ja ihnen selbst die Stärke, deren DNA. Wenn wir gerne zu einem anderen Spiel kommen, wo ein Trainer das getan hat, und das schadet dir ja dann selber, wenn du dich deine eigenen Schwächen beraubst. Dementsprechend glaube ich schon, dass Liverpool, ich dachte, schauen wir mal, wer stärker ist, und dann haben wir halt so ein Spiel bekommen. Also es war richtig, richtig, richtig schön anzusehen.
Aber würdest du sagen, bei Brighton hat sich nochmal was verändert jetzt im Vergleich zur letzten Saison?
Also ich hab jetzt nicht so mega, also ich hab das letzte Spiel jetzt nicht so gesehen. Aber ich hab mit Benny letztens nochmal gesprochen, der meint halt schon, ja, so kleinere Anpassungen gibt es schon. Aber im Grunde genommen ist es noch immer Plan A. Und dem ziehen sie einfach durch. Und das ist, ja, sie haben in der letzten Podcast gesagt, sie haben den schönsten Plan A der Welt, aber sie haben halt nur Plan A.
Genau, danke. Werde ich hier natürlich auch verlinken in den Show Notes die neue Sendung auf Twitch, die ihr sehen könnt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber dann lass doch mal noch auf das zweite Spiel kommen, das werden bestimmt auch viele mitbekommen haben. Arsenal gegen Manchester City und tatsächlich Arsenal gewinnt mit 1 zu 0. Aber da musst du mir jetzt helfen, Jogi. Ich habe dieses Spiel nicht sehen können, weil ich ja immer mit meinem Bundesliga-Quatsch beschäftigt bin. Ich habe das Ergebnis gesehen. Dann habe ich mir Statistiken angesehen und habe gesehen, dass Arsenal 12 zu 4 Schüsse, da haben sie wirklich die Schotten dichtgemacht gegen City. Dann habe ich die Expected Goals gesehen, und da war aber City so leicht vor Arsenal. Also sprich, in diesen 4 Schüssen müssen unglaublich gute Chancen mit dabei gewesen sein. Wie war es denn jetzt, dieses Spiel?
Ja, es war... Ich habe auch was ab der zweiten Hälfte, weil ich hatte zuvor noch ein Spiel und bin erst nach Hause. Ich habe es erst ab der Halbzeitpause gesehen, ein bisschen davor. Aber ich persönlich war von Manchester City sehr enttäuscht, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Allein die Aufstellung... Wir haben danach diese Frage gestellt bekommen, weil ja, Arteta wechselt 3-mal ein. Oder 4-mal ein, glaube ich. Und diese 4 sind an dem entscheidenden Tor beteiligt. Also langer Ball, Ablage, weitergelegt und rein. Das waren genau die 4. Und dann haben sie sich die Frage gestellt, hat Arsenal den Sieg mal wieder eingewechselt oder macht diese Formulierung überhaupt Sinn? Und wir haben dann eigentlich die Frage weitergegeben an Benny und an Flo Blüchel, Scout bei Arsenal gewesen. Und wir haben uns so ein bisschen rumphilosophiert. Und Flo meinte, ich glaube nicht, dass dort der Sieg eingewechselt worden ist bei Arsenal, sondern ich glaube eher, dass Pep die Nürnlage aufgestellt hat. Und das ist glaube ich das sehr interessante daran, weil wenn du dir das anschaust, er hat nominell jetzt in der Führerkette nichts anderes gemacht, aber taktisch schon. Also Kyle Walker, der ja eigentlich den inversen Innenverteidiger gelernt, gefühlt erfunden hat, spielte plötzlich die Linie rauf und runter. Und man merkte, dass es einfach nicht mehr so kann, dass es auch nicht sein Ding ist, sondern dass er einfach viel, viel besser ist, wenn er dann eben aus der Tiefe kommt und wenn er dort eben im Aufbau beteiligt sein kann und dann auch mal in der Restverteidigung einen abgrätschen kann. Das sind seine Stärken. Er ist aber die Linie rauf und runter. Er hat mit Rico Luis im Mittelfeld gespielt, das ist ein Außenverteidiger. Und jetzt wird es am allerinteressantesten, ja, Rodri ist gesperrt, aber er spielt auf der 6 mit Bernardo Silva. Und das sind natürlich schon so Dinge, also ich finde, das passt einfach nicht. Gerade gegen Arsenal mit dem Declan Rice, der hatte ich allein schon mal physisch statt dem Überlegen, da hat er schon ein paar Duelle gewonnen. Da konnte Bernardo nichts dafür, der hat auch nicht schlecht gespielt, aber ich persönlich würde mir eher denken, es fehlt de Bruyne und es fehlt Rodri. Dann versuche ich wenigstens Bernardo Silva als den kreativeren Part zu verwenden. Und für die 6 muss ich mir etwas überlegen. Dann stelle ich da vielleicht, keine Ahnung, er hat ja genügend Leute und das wird da vielleicht noch etwas Kreatives einfallen. Du hast Matthäus Nulisch für fast 60 Millionen geholt und den lässt auf der Bank sitzen. Du hast letzte Saison Kevin Phillips für 40 Millionen geholt und den lässt er auf der Bank sitzen. Dass du denen nicht vertraust und dass du sagst, Bernardo Silva wird Rodri sein, also das glaube ich ist nett gedacht auf den ersten Blick, aber hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Und nach vorne, muss ich sagen, waren sie so unkreativ, es ist lang nicht mehr Hauk-Fußball und Tiki-Taka, das ist auch vorbei, aber das war so einfach auf Absicherung bedacht, um Arsenal keine Räume zu geben, dass sie nach vorne überhaupt nichts hinbekommen. Expected Goals, Erling Haaland 0,00. Das sagt eigentlich auch eine Menge.
Das ist schon eine interessante Entwicklung bei City. Wie ist das denn? Pep Guardiola fällt ja wegen einer Rücken-OP, kann er eine ganze Weile nicht an der Seitenlinie stehen, war er jetzt in dem Spiel wieder richtig am Couchen oder saß er wieder auf der Tribüne?
Nee, das war jetzt schon das vierte und fünfte Mal da. Ich hab das erste Mal gehabt, als er zurückkam. Ich glaub, gegen West Ham kam er zurück bei mir. Das müsste vor ein paar Wochen gewesen sein.
Da sieht man mal, dass ich das überhaupt nicht mitbekommen habe. Aber wo steht denn jetzt dann City deiner Meinung nach? Ich meine, die Bilanz ist natürlich immer noch gut. Zwei Niederlagen, sechs Siege. Natürlich nervt das jetzt dann, dass man auch dieses Spiel dann auch die Art und Weise, wie man es verloren hat. Aber es ist ja alles sehr, sehr eng. Also Tottenham, aktuell Tabellenführer, Arsenal. Punkt gleicht, beide 20 Punkte, beide eine Plus-10er-Tor-Differenz. Dann Manchester City, die haben plus 18 Punkte. Liverpool haben 17 Punkte. Und Aston Villa und Brighton, die könnte man jetzt rein theoretisch noch dazurechnen. Die sind vier Punkte dahinter. Das ist jetzt natürlich dann wahrscheinlich eher Makulatur. Da wird noch eine Lücke aufgehen. Aber die oberen vier sind sehr eng beieinander.
Wo steht da City im Vergleich mit den anderen dreien?
Ich finde es ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht schlimm, dass es so ist, wie es ist. Ich könnte die Schriftliche suchen, müsste jetzt echt ein bisschen kramen im Laptop. Aber es ist bei City eigentlich traditionell so, dass sie in den ersten 13 Spielen, das ist immer so der Cut, wo man in einer englischen Zeitung die Vergleiche gemacht hat, die lassen immer Punkte in den ersten 13 Spielen. Das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt schlimm. Die Überraschung war, das habe ich ja immer gesagt, auch in den Spielen, die Überraschung ist, dass City die ersten sechs Spiele oder was es waren, gewonnen hat. Das war die Überraschung, dass sie so rauskommen. Auch da ist es noch nicht gerollt, dass man sagen könnte, wow, das ist ja unglaublich, was die spielen. Und trotzdem haben sie die Spiele gewonnen. Das ist die Gefahr jetzt für alle anderen, dass wenn City jetzt schon nicht rollt, dass sie nie tun. Die kommen nie gut raus. Die haben ja immer am Schluss diese 11 Spiele Siegesserie, 10 Spiele Siegesserie. Aber dass sie am Anfang schon die Siegesserie haben, das sollte wirklich allen Angst machen. Wenn es dann so weitergeht, dann wissen wir auch, wie es bei Guardiola laufen kann. Dann sind die im März schon Meister. Und hatten wir ja in deiner geliebten Bundesliga das Öfteren. Also insofern, das gibt es. Insofern, in unserer Geliebten muss man sagen, ich bin ja da nicht raus. Aber das ist dann eben das, wo ich mir wirklich Sorgen gemacht habe um die Premier League, dass City wieder weglaufen wird. Dass die jetzt so eine kleine Delle haben, finde ich jetzt nicht so schlimm, ehrlich gesagt. Ich meine, gegen Arsenal, die hätten noch unentschieden spielen können. Wenn Rotir dabei gewesen wäre, glaube ich, wäre es ein ganz anderes Spiel gewesen, weil der liegt Arsenal gar nicht. Das ist einfach der beste Sechser der Welt. Ich bleibe dabei, auch wenn es... Da gibt es ja auch Kritiker, die sagen, momentan ist er ein bisschen über drüber, wie auch immer. Ich liebe diesen Spieler. Und ich glaube, mit dem wäre es ganz anders ausgegangen. Dann hätte Bernardo Silva eine andere Rolle spielen können. Dann hätte Calvo keine andere Rolle spielen können, weil das hat ja seine Gründe, dass alles so verschoben worden ist. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass City dann eine Chance gehabt hätte, zumindest einen Punkt zu holen. Und dann hätte keiner darüber diskutiert. Und vor allem, man muss auch sagen, der Schuss von Martinelli war ein abgefälschtes Ding. Also das ist reiner Zufall, dass der reingeht am Ende des Tages. Und dann gewinnen die jetzt und alle sagen, ah, das hat City geknackt. Ja, stimmt, aber hätte auch anders ausgehen können. So ist es jetzt nicht, dass man jetzt sagen müsste, das war ein klarer Asen-Sieg. So war es jetzt auch wieder nicht.
Ja, wenn du ein Power-Ranking aus diesen vier Teams machen würdest, also dann City auf eins, so wie ich es jetzt rausgehört habe, oder wie wäre die Reihenfolge aktuell?
Wenn wir zwei Nierlagen jetzt am Stück, da bin ich natürlich jetzt echt schwer. Dann glaube ich, muss man eigentlich, also ich persönlich muss sagen, so Hardfacts-Power-Ranking ist vielleicht ein anderes, aber so gefühlt Power-Ranking Nummer eins für mich totnehmen, weil es einfach momentan das Team ist, wenn du dir so ein Smiley vorstellst. Das ist ein grüner Smiley mit einem Grinsen. Und den hat Tottenham einfach momentan als einziges Team. Bei denen läuft wirklich alles und weit besser als ich zu dem Zeitpunkt glaube ich auch gedacht und geplant hatten. Deswegen würde ich so, aber wir alle wissen, vom Kader her ist Tottenham jetzt nicht das Beste. Deswegen, aber von der Form her, von dem wie die momentan spielen, von dem wie die momentan drauf sind, würde ich jetzt einfach mal Tottenham sagen. Dann vielleicht Arsenal, dann Liverpool würde ich jetzt auch da oben mitnehmen. Das sind die so, diese vier sind es einfach momentan.
Okay, Tottenham und Arsenal ja auch die einzigen beiden Teams, die noch umgeschlagen sind in der Liga.
Eine Sache haben wir noch. Bei diesem Spiel gab es ja auch noch Kovacic, der eigentlich hätte rot sehen müssen. Da haben die Engländer mal wieder ihr Schiedsrichterproblem der ganzen Welt offenbart. Also Kovacic, Foul, Odegaard. Da diskutieren Leute schon über Serious Foul Play, also ein echtes Foul Spiel. Wird sich angeschaut. Es gibt eine gelbe Karte. Fünf Minuten später, weiß nicht mehr, nagelt mich jetzt bitte nicht fest, aber haut er Decan Rice um, Ball ist weg, er haut ihm hinten diese voll in die Knöchel rein von hinten. Und dafür gibt es gar nichts. Also selbst wenn man sagen würde, okay, das erste war keine rote Karte, beides waren gelbe Karten. Also Kovacic hätte auf jeden Fall bis zur Halbzeitpause nicht mehr auf dem Feld stehen dürfen. Und da, glaube ich, hat, muss man auch sagen, hat City wahrscheinlich auch Glück, in Anführungszeichen, dass sie verloren haben. Das wären auch meine riesen Shitstorm gewesen in Richtung der Schiedsrichter, in Richtung von Manchester City, weil das waren beides für mich gelbe Karten. Ganz ganz klar. Die erste war, es gibt Hartleine, die werden sagen, das ist schon eine rote Karte. Da würde ich jetzt nicht mitgehen in der Premier League bei so einem Spiel um diese Uhrzeit, bei diesem Spielstand zu dieser, ja, bei dieser Spieldauer von viertel Stunde oder wie auch immer. Da würde ich jetzt nicht machen, aber beides insgesamt sind als gelbe Karten zu bewerten. Da haben wir echt nur mal Glück. Die Schiedsrichter-Gilde hat momentan echt ein Problem dort.
Aber ist es denn möglich, in der Premier League gelbe Karten auch zu reviewen, oder ist es da wie in Deutschland das nur Platz verweise? Entsprechend konnte dann Michael Oliver da nicht mehr geholfen werden vom VAA.
Ja, da lässt sich auch Ungern helfen, das ist das Problem.
Als ich es gesagt habe, dachte ich mir, war das nicht derjenige, der immer bei seiner Entscheidung bleibt.
Das siehst du dem schon an, dass er sich denkt, was wollt ihr eigentlich? Das ist sehr ignorant, ehrlich gesagt. Aber das muss man ihm auch zugute halten, der ist immer ein Hardliner. Der pfeift sehr wenig und gibt auch sehr spät esgäbe Karten. Deswegen, das ist seine Linie. Der hat nichts verlassen, was man nicht kennt oder so.
Okay, wieder eine Schiedsrichter-Kontroverse. Dann lass mal zu den Awards kommen. MVP, Anzang Hero und Moment des Spieltags.
MVP würde ich sagen, der Glen Rice. Weil er dieses Spiel wirklich definiert und dominiert. Und hat gezeigt, dass er auf diesem Niveau Arsene einfach noch mal ein Stückchen besser macht. Deswegen würde ich sagen, der Glen Rice, der geht manchmal so wenig unter, weil er nur ein zentral defensiver Mittelfeldspieler ist. Ich habe Gerüchte gehört, dass sie in der Vorbereitung überlegt haben, ich glaube, der ist vielleicht doch nicht der Problemlöser. Wir sollten uns einen Plan B überlegen. Der ist momentan sowas von der Problemlöser. Der ist richtig gut und ist so wichtig. Wir haben es gesehen, in dem Spiel gegen Tottenham, als der raus war, war die ganze Sicherheit weg. Und das, glaube ich, war schon sehr wichtig in diesem Spiel, weil Arsene eben das gegeben hat, was gegen City sonst immer gefehlt hat. Würde ich sagen, Kieron Trippier. Der hat jetzt schon sechs Vorlagen in dieser Saison, wenn ich mich alles täusche, oder fünf. Ich hatte das Spiel eben West Ham gegen Newcastle und der hat wieder ein Spiel gemacht. Der gibt Vorlage wiedergegeben. Der ist an allem beteiligt, was kreativ ist. Nach hinten super clever. Überhaupt einer der kreativsten Außenverteidiger, mit die meisten Chancen kreiert, überhaupt in der Premier League, aber die meisten Außenverteidiger. Der spielt so eine gute Saison und ist einfach auch so ein guter Fußballer und auch ein guter Typ für diese Mannschaft. Und das, glaube ich, haben wirklich die wenigsten auf dem Schirm, was der da momentan spielt. Vielleicht der Premier League-Fan, vielleicht nicht so. Und deswegen sage ich, das ist absolut der Anzang-Hero, weil gerade das Außenverteidiger sowieso.
Ja, hat ja auch eine Rolle gespielt beim 4 zu 1 gegen PSG. Das war natürlich ein Ergebnis, das haben wahrscheinlich viele mitbekommen. Jetzt unter der Woche war das, in der letzten Woche. Und welchen Moment des Spieltags hast du? Ich hoffe, es hat nicht mit Schiedsrichtern zu tun.
Da würde ich tatsächlich einfach wirklich diesen Moment nehmen mit Martinelli. Dass der das Tor macht und wie Arsenal dann gepoppt ist, das glaube ich, muss man schon sagen. Die haben jetzt so lange nicht gewonnen gegen Manchester City. Guardiola hat so lange nicht besiegt. Dann outtügt die Geschichte dann noch drum, dass es dann auch Querelen unten an den Katakomben gab. Dass der Standard-Trainer von Arsenal sich so ein bisschen demonstrativ hingestellt hat, die Hände in den Rücken, so quasi euch gebe ich die Hand heute nicht. Man merkt da wirklich, was da zwischen den Mannschaften momentan für eine Spannung ist. Auch wenn die beiden, Guardiola und Arteta, sich mögen, brauchen wir nicht reden. Die sind die einzigen beiden, die wirklich in die Katakomben gehen und die Klappe halten, weil sie wollen einfach gar nicht verführt werden. Aber man merkt, was da los ist zwischen diesen beiden Teams. Man merkt auch, was zwischen den Fanlagern los ist. Und diese Rivalität, City gegen Liverpool, das war die Rivalität der letzten fünf Jahre. Das ist geswitcht. Also mittlerweile schon Arsenal gegen Man City. Das ist momentan die beiden größten Teams, muss man schon sagen. Und dass Arsenal das nach Ewigkeit mal gewinnen konnte und was das auch mit den Emirates gemacht hat, ist, glaube ich, schon etwas historisches gewesen, was wir, glaube ich, aus der deutschen Sicht jetzt gar nicht so sehen können. Aber wie die abgegangen sind, die Fans, glaube ich, für die ist das etwas ganz Besonderes gewesen. Und natürlich auch für die ganze Saison jetzt, weil Ars natürlich City jetzt wirklich geschlagen hat. Was macht das mit Arsenal? Was macht das mit City? Kommen die zurück? Erst recht. Wie reagiert Garniola drauf taktisch? Natürlich auch das, dass City das jetzt nicht gewonnen hat, ist natürlich auch gut für die Tabelle, weil jetzt sind die alle enger zusammen. Deswegen, das, glaube ich, ist jetzt einfach nur ein Spiel gewesen. Aber für uns alle als Fußballfans ist es das Allerbeste, weil jetzt diese Saison, glaube ich, erst richtig losgeht. Weil jetzt sind jetzt alle so, jeder hat mal einige Watsch bekommen, so gefühlt. Und das ist, glaube ich, ganz gut für die Liga, weil jetzt einfach natürlich alle so auf einem Level sind.
Außer die Spurs und Arsenal, aber das wird auch noch kommen.
Ja, aber Arsenal hat ja Gefühl da auch schon eine bekommen, weil, ich meine, Nortten David nicht gewonnen nach zweifacher Führung. So meinte ich, jeder hat schon irgendwie ein Spiel mal abgegeben, wo du dir denkst, boah, das wäre eigentlich unnötig gewesen. Und das hat Arsenal auch schon, die haben das mit Sicherheit als Niederlage gesehen, nach zweifacher Führung. Und Storzino verliert den Ball vor dem eigenen Strafraum und der Gegner rennt alleine drauf zu. Also das war eine Niederlage. Auch wenn es mit Punkte von ging, aber gefühlt war das eine Niederlage.
Ja, hast du recht. Das macht richtig Bock, danach der Länderspielpause wieder reinzugucken. Was sind denn die Matches, die uns dann nicht entgehen lassen sollten?
Ja, da hast du mich auf wirklich kalt erwischt. Aber jetzt kann ich natürlich einen ganz einfachen Call machen, weil der Mercyside-Derby Liverpool gegen Everton ist natürlich immer etwas Besonderes. Chelsea gegen Arsenal ist danach auch noch auch interessant. Und dann natürlich auch, das habe ich sogar, glaube ich, wenn ich alles täusche, Manchester City gegen Brighton. Ich hatte das letzte Saison kurz vor Schluss. Das war taktisch eines der interessantesten Spiele, die ich jemals gesehen habe, weil De Zerbi gegen Guardiola. Die beiden schätzen sich, die beiden mögen sich. De Zerbi ist ja extra mal aus Italien nach München gereist, um Guardiola bei Bayern München einfach zuzuschauen. Da war er noch Amateurtrainer. Die beiden lieben sich über allem. Und die beiden jetzt gegeneinander zu sehen, muss ich schon sagen, das ist immer interessant und ist taktisch der absolute Oberkracher. Frenzi Arsenal immer. Aber so ein Spiel hast du halt immer jede Woche in der Premier League, dass einer großer gegen den anderen großen spielt. Das ist jetzt, glaube ich, immer interessant, aber es ist auch nicht so spektakulär. Und Merseyside-Darby ist, glaube ich, auch so unausgeglichen wie seit ewigen Jahren nicht mehr. Aber genau dann wird es immer gefährlich in solchen Darbys.
Genau, das wollte ich schon sagen.
Wir haben so viel da drin, also es ist wirklich sehr interessant. Jede Woche so.
Also, das wird schön, wenn es weitergeht am 21. und 22. Oktober. Jogi, ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank dir. Und sag doch nochmal kurz, wo kann man dich denn jetzt bei RondoTV sehen? Was ist RondoTV und so weiter und so fort?
Vielen Dank dafür. Also, das heißt, wir sind bei Twitch. Schrägstrich das RondoTV. Es ist eine Fußball-Sendung, die wir jetzt ins Leben gerufen haben, mit Benny Grund, Videoanalyste eines Bundesligisten. Ich glaube, er mag es ziemlich so gern, wenn man sagt, wann wo. Flo Blüchel, ehemaliger Scout von Arsenal, ehemaliger Scout Bayern München, der momentan sich einem privaten Projekt widmet, eben auch uns. Und das ist natürlich überragend, weil du hast einen, der spieltaktisch die Welt erklären kann. Du hast einen, der individualtaktisch oder vom Spielerprofiler die Welt erklären kann. Und du hast mit Uli und mir zwei Holzköpfe, die das einfach versuchen, irgendwo rein zu pressen. Und die jetzt auch schon mal ein paar Spiele gesehen haben. Das ist, glaube ich, insgesamt schon eine coole Combo. Wir machen Reactions auf Spiele, Reactions auf Pressekonferenzen. Wir schauen einfach mal ein Spiel an, so Watchalongs. Wir reden aber auch einfach über Themen, machen irgendwie über Vereine. Zum Beispiel, letztens ging es um die Hertha. Wir haben einfach erklärt, was macht die Hertha momentan, was macht sie falsch, was macht sie richtig. Und so Teamprofile und was könnte besser sein. Dann fragt man Flo wieder, welcher Spieler würde da reinpassen. Das ist einfach so, versuchen die Expertisen auszunutzen. Und er macht mega Spaß und wächst stetig, dauert immer so ein bisschen auf Twitch. Aber du bist auch gerne mal eingeladen. Ich soll dich von allen grüßen und dich gerne einladen.
Ja, ich weiß zwar nicht, wie ich da jetzt noch reinpasse, aber ich komm gerne mal und grüße sehr herzlich zurück. Also es wird alles verlinkt werden. Danke dir, Oli, für deine Zeit. Sehr gerne. Und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Wie immer geht der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist allein crowdfinanziert. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann und auch kleine Beträge helfen. Und auch wenn ihr nur die Ligatur zum Beispiel hört, dann überlegt euch doch, welchen Wert hat das denn für euch, dass wir hier wöchentlich über 2. Männerbundesliga und die europäischen Top-Ligen der Männer sprechen. Und diesen Wert lasst ihr uns dann zukommen. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.